أنا ما عندي مشكلة مع المشاهير، ولا عندي مشكلة مع المؤثرين صدقني
ولكن عندي مشكلة مع تسطيح القضية، ومع تسطيح الموضوع
وأنا عندي مشكلة مع الجهات الحكومية
التي غير قادرة على تطوير نفسها وللا تطوير أدواتها
فتقوم بضخ كل ميزانياتها الإعلامية للاستعانة بمشاهير للترويج لها
أنت من مؤسسين «الأوبك» وأنت مؤسس «الأوبك بلس»
وأنت تقريبًا مُتحكم باقتصاد النفط في العالم
عدد الصحفيين المتخصصين في النفط في السعودية
لا يتجاوز أصابع اليد الواحدة مش اليدين
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقة اليوم هو الأستاذ عضوان الأحمري
خبير في الإعلام ورئيس تحرير «الاندبندنت العربية»
حلقة يمكن أسلوبها مختلف عن سقراط
لأن قطاع الإعلام بشكل عام ما في مشروع واضح
أو مستهدفات واضحة نقدر نتابع تحقيقها مع ضيوفنا
فكانت الحلقة تشخيص عام واستعراض عام لواقع الإعلام
يمكن الكثيرين غير راضين عن الحراك في قطاع الإعلام الفترة الماضية
وفي نفس الوقت في تفاؤل للفترة القادمة
بقيادة الأستاذ «سلمان الدوسري» معالي وزير الإعلام
فهذا خلانا نحاول نفهم من ضيفنا
أيش توقعاته لمشروع السعودية في قطاع الإعلام؟
أيش دور الإعلام الرسمي؟ أيش دور الإعلام المستقل؟
أيش الخطوط الحمراء في قطاع الإعلام؟
كيف ممكن نزيد من قوة هذا الإعلام؟
وهل هو اليوم مؤثر في العالم العربي أو غير مؤثر؟
وختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
أترككم مع الحوار
حياك الله أبو محمد شرفتنا ونورتنا
أهلًا وسهلًا عمر، كيف الحال؟
الله يحييك
أيش أخبارك؟
الحمد لله على السلامة
الله يسلمك
إن شاء الله، رحلة جيدة؟
الحمد لله
أبو محمد أنت إدارة أعمال تخصصك في الجامعة
أيش دخلك في الإعلام؟
وليش والدك، الله يحفظه، ما كان يبيك تدخل إعلام؟
أول شيء شكرًا لك على الاستضافة، شكرًا لسقراط
تخصصي إدارة الأعمال أنا ما أعتقد...
هذه الإجابة ممكن تكون محببة لأقسام الإعلام في السعودية
لكن أنك تدرس صحافة ما تخليك صحفي
وأنك تدرس إعلام ما تخليك إعلامي
وأكثر كليات الإعلام في المملكة العربية السعودية لوقت قريب
كانت التخصصات أكثرها إما إذاعة وتلفزيون
بدون ما يوجد مسار صحفي متخصص في الإعلام الرقمي
وحتى في الإعلام الحديث
فأنا درست إدارة أعمال، ولكن الماجستير كان في الإعلام الرقمي
بس الشغف وقتها كان إعلام
أتوقع وأنا في السنة الأولى من الجامعة كنت أكتب في صحيفة «الوطن»
ما شاء الله، أيش اللي دخلك هذا العالم؟
قبل الصحافة كنت أحب أكتب في المنتديات، وكنت أحب أن أكتب في ...
في التعليق على الأحداث السياسية، ولكن حتى بدون نشر
فكان كل فترة أجمع مجموعة مقالات، وأعطيها للوالد لآخذ رأيه
فكان يحاول صرف النظر عن هذا الموضوع
وكان هو هدفه أني أدخل إما في مجال التجارة
أو حتى أني أدخل في مجال عمل آخر
لكن بعدما شاف الابن العنيد بدأ يكتب
وبدأت تُنشَر له مقالات في الصفحة الأخيرة في صحيفة «الوطن»
وما تجاوز وقتها عمري أتوقع أربع وعشرين أو خمس وعشرين سنة
فبدأ الحديث بشفافية عن أنه كان صحفي، وأطلعني على بعض التاريخ الجميل
أنت ما كنت تعرف أبدًا؟
أبدًا
وكنت تستغرب من السلام اللي يُرسَل من «عبدالرحمن الراشد»؟
لا أنا أرسلت بريد إلكتروني لـ«عبدالرحمن الراشد» يمكن ذكرتها قبل
أنا أرسلت بريد إلكتروني لـ«عبدالرحمن الراشد» كنت أتمنى...
تحققت الأمنية بعد عشر سنوات، أن أدخل صحيفة «الشرق الأوسط»
وهو كان رئيس تحرير «الشرق الأوسط»
فأرسلت له أطلب منه نشر مقال في صفحة الرأي
فكتب لي زميل عزيز، وابن زميلٍ العزيز
فهذه هي اللي أثارت فضول الصحفي المختفي أو المتخبي زي ما يقولون
فسألت الوالد، قلت: «عبدالرحمن الراشد» يقول: زميل عزيز ابن زميل العزيز
وبعدها اكتشفت الـ...
الوضع كله واسطة في واسطة
أنت دخلت القطاع بواسطة من والدك؟
لا، أنا كنت في جريدة «الوطن» غير صحيح
أنا أتشرف لو الواسطة كان لها دور مع كفاءة فلا يعيب الإنسان
لكن لا، غير صحيح أبدًا، أنا بعدما دخلت في الصحافة
وبعدما صرت أكتب في صحيفة «الوطن» عرفت هذه المعلومة
بعدما ترك «عبدالرحمن الراشد» رئاسة تحرير «الشرق الأوسط»
أنا دخلت للـ«شرق الأوسط» في بداية 2013 نهاية 2012
بدأ الحديث من صحيفة «الشرق الأوسط»
دخلت المجال الرقمي أنت وللا لا؟
كنت رئيس الموقع الرقمي والأونلاين لمدة ست سنوات في «الشرق الوسط»
وبعدها كانت خطوة «اندبندت عربية» صح؟
«اندبندت عربية» توقيع العقد يونيو 2018
الإعداد لها بدأ من أكتوبر 2018، الانطلاق في يناير 2019
إن شاء الله، نكمل خمس سنوات بعد كم شهر
عساك على القوة، احنا أبو محمد مرة مبسوطين للاستضافة هذه
لأننا مهتمين نفهم الحراك اللي صار في القطاع الإعلامي
من القطاعات اللي ما في وضوح على الأقل للي يتابع من برة مثلي
ما في وضوح وين نبي نروح
أنت داخل القطاع
أقصد من خارج الجهات الرسمية أو جهات العمل المؤسسي في الإعلام
لأن لما أشوف برامج تحقيق الرؤية أو أشوف المستهدفات
ما في شيء واضح بخصوص وين نبي نصل في قطاع الإعلام؟
كل القطاعات الأخرى اسألني عنها
راح أقول لك: قطاع الصحة وين نبي نكون، وقطاع الطاقة وين نبي نكون
قطاع الرياضة وين نبي نكون، المستهدفات مرة واضحة
قطاع الإعلام ما هو واضح، أيش هو مشروع السعودية؟
ما هو واضح الحراك الفترة الماضية، كيف شكله؟
ففي كثير من الأسئلة راح أسولف عنها
بس خليني أبدأ بسؤال مربوط بتغريدة لك في مارس 2021
كان جدل أو نقاش بينك وبين الأمير «عبدالرحمن بن مساعد»
الأمير «عبدالرحمن» كان عنده لقاء
وذكر فيه بأن الإعلام السعودي
لم يقم بدوره في التعريف بإنجازات السعودية والدفاع عنها
فأنت كتبت تغريدة حادة شوي في مسألة أن...
ما كان فيها أسماء
لكن واضح الربط بطبيعة الحال
التغريدة بالضبط تقول فيها: «من الجهل بالإعلام
الظن أن الإعلام دوره نقل الإنجازات للعالم أو الدفاع
هذا دور العلاقات العامة والدبلوماسية وقبلها وزارة الخارجية
نقل الصورة إلى الخارج هو بفتح الباب للأجنبي للسياحة والإطلاع على النهضة
ومخالطة الناس وهذا ما يحدث برؤية طموحة يقودها الأمير محمد بن سلمان»
الأمير «عبدالرحمن بن مساعد» رجع رد عليك رد
إلى الآن ما أعرف هل هو جاد وللا يتهكم؟
كان يقول: كنت قلت البارحة في لقاء تلفزيوني أنني أرى أن هناك قصورًا
من جانب الإعلام السعودي في الخارج، وأنه لم يُوّفق في نقل الإنجازات
ولم يُوّفق في التصدي والدفاع عن السعودية
واليوم غرد الأستاذ عضوان موضحًا أنه من الجهل بالإعلام بالاعتقاد أن دوره
نقل الإنجازات والدفاع عن البلد
ولأن الأستاذ عضوان إعلامي متمرس
ومتخصص في الإعلام، وأنا لست كذلك، أتراجع عن ما قلت
وأقول: أن إعلامنا في الخارج يؤدي دوره على أكمل وجه
والقصور إن وُجد فهو في فهمنا لدور الإعلام
أول شيء، تتوقع رده كان جاد أو تهكمي؟
كان تهكمي
تهكم ها؟
مع الود والتقدير
صار بينكم وبينه حوار بعدها؟
بلا شك، هو الأمير «عبدالرحمن بن مساعد» له الود والتقدير والاحترام
وأرسلت له باركت له أيضًا بصدور ديوانه الشعري
وهناك نسخة موقعة لم أحصل عليها حتى الآن بسبب تقصير مني
العلاقة طيبة جدًا، هو الأمير «عبدالرحمن بن مساعد» رمز في مجاله
وشاهدنا الإبداع اللي قام به في «معلقاتنا امتداد أمجاد»
ولكن في موضوع الإعلام أنا أعتقد هذه التغريدة...
خلنا نبدأ من هنا أبو محمد
ما زلت أتمسك فيها لأن فعلًا هذا الواقع إذا تسمح لي
صحيح، هذا أهم نقاش راح يكون اليوم، أيش هو دور الإعلام؟
في وجهة نظر عند الأمير «عبدالرحمن»
تبغى التغريدة هذه أو تبغى بشكل عام؟
خلينا نتكلم عن التغريدة وبشكل عام، خذ راحتك
أولًا: أنت بدأت الحوار بتسخين مباشر
لا، احنا نبي نسولف
سؤال ساخن، لكن أعطيك مثال إذا تسمح لي
سم
اليوم تخيل أنك تذهب إلى الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية أو إلى المملكة المتحدة
أو إلى أي دولة في العالم، وتتحدث مع بريطاني أو مع أمريكي أو مع أي جنسية
وتقول له: لدينا أفضل منظومة خدمات إلكترونية حكومية
ولدينا أفضل تطبيق لإنجاز المعاملات اسمه «أبشر»
كيف تتوقع ردة فعله؟
هذا الأمر لا يهمه نهائي، ولكن حينما تفتح باب التأشيرات السياحية
ويأتي هذا الأمريكي أو البريطاني إلى البلد
ويقوم بإنجاز جميع معاملاته دون واسطة
أو حتى دون انتظار في طابور أو إلى آخره
هو الذي سينقل هذه الصورة إلى الخارج، هذا واحد
الأمر الثاني كان هناك مثال حيوي في فترة كورونا
في فترة كورونا حينما كان الحجر
وكان الإبهار السعودي في موضوع اللقاحات
وفي موضوع المسحات والاهتمام والرعاية
وفي موضوع الحجر المجاني إلى آخره
شاهدنا مقاطع لدبلوماسي أمريكي يتحدث عن هذا
وشاهدنا لكثير من المقيمين من الجنسية الهندية والفلبينية
عبر التيك توك وعبر وسائل مختلفة
يثبت ما أقوله: بأن نقل الصورة للخارج
تأتي بفتح المجال للآخر حتى يزورك، ويعرف ما لديك
السعودية عانت مثلًا بعد 11 سبتمبر
من صورة ذهنية مرتبطة بأنها دولة ترعى الإرهاب
وأن شعبها متشدد، وهذا الكلام غير صحيح
لكن تخيل من عام 2001 لم تُفتَح التأشيرات السياحية إلا عام 2019
ففي كل هذه الفترة هناك صورة ذهنية أنت غير قادر على تصحيحها
الإعلام لا يمكن تحميله هذا الأمر
حتى فترة قريبة كان كثير من الأماكن السياحية ومنها «العلا»
دعنا نقول: جوهرة التاج فيما يتعلق بالسياحة الداخلية
كان مُحرّم زيارة آثارها، وكان عليها سياج، ولا يُسمَح بالدخول
فتخيل تحميل الإعلام كل هذا، لا يمكن
الخدمات الإلكترونية اللي تروّجها للمواطن الأمريكي
المواطن الأمريكي يجب أن تفتح له المجال حتى يأتي ويزور، ويعرف ما لديك
ويعرف طبيعة الشعب، ويعرف هذا الشعب المضياف الكريم
ونشاهده حتى في كثير من المقاطع
التي يستغرب فيها سائح أجنبي كرم الشعب وينبهر
حتى المقطع في اليوم الوطني كان مقطع جميل
كان هناك مقيمة أوربية أو سائحة وتريد العلم
فشخص كان لديه علم واحد
حتى لو كان البعض يرى المثال هذا بسيط أو سطحي أمر يعود لهم
أتى بالعلم، ولم تصدق أن هذا الاحتكاك البسيط هو الذي ينقل الصورة للخارج
لكن صدقني كل دولة في العالم مشغولة بأمورها الداخلية
مشغولة بهمومها الداخلية وبمعيشتها الداخلية
لن تلتفت إلى إنجازات أي دولة عبر الإعلام، أو حتى عبر نشرات الأخبار
إذا سلّمنا بأنه من وجهة نظرك ليس دور الإعلام نقل إنجازات
أيش دور الإعلام؟
الإعلام أنواع، لما أقول: دور الإعلام ليس نقل إنجازات
فأنا أجمع الإعلام كله في سلة واحدة
هناك الإعلام الرسمي المباشر
ويتمثل في جميع الوسائل التابعة «لهيئة الإذاعة والتلفزيون»
وهناك «وكالة الأنباء السعودية الرسمية»
وهناك الحسابات التابعة للتواصل الحكومي
وهناك وزارة الخارجية بنشاطها الإعلامي
وهناك «مركز الملك سلمان للإغاثة والأعمال الإنسانية»
كل هذه الجهات تقوم بنشر ما تفعله عبر منصاتها
لكن إعلام موجه للعالم العربي أو إعلام ممول أو إعلام مستَثمر فيه
سواءً إعلام بعلامات تجارية أمريكية أو بريطانية لا يقوم بنقل إنجازات واجبة
واجبه نقل الحقيقة والنقد وتسليط الضوء على بعض التفاصيل الحقيقية
وأن يسير بالمسار الذي من أجله استثمر هذا الشخص أو تلك الدولة فيه
لكن دور الإعلام بنقل الإنجازات والدفاع عن الوطن هذا واجبنا الأساسي كأفراد
المؤسسات الرسمية كما قسّمتها لك هناك إعلام مباشر وغير مباشر
وهناك إعلام ممول وهناك إعلام رسمي، صعب جمعها في سلة واحدة
ولهذا دائمًا الضرب في الإعلام، ووضع اللوم على الإعلام
لا يمكن أن يأتي دون جمع الحقائق كاملة
أولًا إذا سمحت لي، فتح السياحة للآخر
وتسهيل التعاملات في الدخول والخروج في البلد
وهذه كلها الآن مُوفّرة
من عام 2019 نعيش قصة تحول حقيقية تحديدًا في مجال السياحة
هي ما تجعل البعض سيستوعب بعد خمس أو عشر سنوات
أن هذا ليس دور الإعلام
وبما أنك صنفتهم إلى مجموعة كيانات مختلفة سواءً الإعلام الرسمي
وللا الإعلام المدعوم أو الإعلام المستقل
خلينا نتكلم عن كل واحد منهم، هل يقوم بدوره؟
لو أخذنا الإعلام الرسمي اليوم
الإعلام الحكومي اللي هو «هيئة الإذاعة» أو «وكالة الأنباء السعودية»
أو «التواصل الحكومي»
هؤلاء أيش دورهم، وأيش تقييمك لدورهم؟
أنا أعتقد أن هناك دور كبير جدًا تقوم به كل هذه الجهات
«مركز التواصل الحكومي» متواجد في الداخل والخارج
سواءً في الفعاليات أو في الأنشطة
ومحاولة أيضًا نقل الصورة الجيدة بأكثر من لغة
«هيئة الإذاعة والتلفزيون» لديها القنوات المحلية
وأنا أعتقد أنها تقوم بدورها، قناة «الإخبارية» تقدم دور إخباري
أنت تتابعها؟
أنا أتابع بعض ما يُنشَر، لا يمكن أنك تتابع كل شيء أربع وعشرين ساعة
هل هي مصدرك الإخباري؟
مصدري الإخباري فيما يتعلق بالأخبار الرسمية «وكالة الأنباء السعودية»
مصدر وحتى «الإخبارية» تستسقي أو تستقي أخبارها من «واس»
اليوم مصدر المعلومات فيه ضخم معلوماتي مخيف جدًّا
حتى التلفزيون، نسبة المشاهدة للتلفزيونات في جميع أنحاء عالم منخفضة
ولكن محتوى التلفزيون هو الباقي
لكن بلا شك «الإخبارية» تطورت تطور كبير
«وكالة الأنباء السعودية» الآن من أكثر من فترة تجد تناقل، وتداول للصور
سواءً في الحج أو في بعض المواسم
وهذا دليل على التطوير وعلى الاحترافية
ما زالت جميع هذه المنظومة الإعلامية
أعتقد بقيادة معالي «سلمان الدوسري» هناك ما زال تطوير
تشاهده من فترة لأخرى
وخصوصًا في «وكالة الأنباء السعودية» أمور كثيرة قادمة
فأنا أعتقد أن الدور إذا كان تعريف الإعلام الرسمي كما قلنا
فأنا أعتقد أنها تقوم بدورها على أكمل وجه
«واس» حينما يكون هناك إعلان جديد لمطار آخر
آخر الإعلانات مثلًا مطار أبها الدولي أو حتى المحمية
التي يُعلَن عنها في جنوب السعودية
ومن أكبر المحميات تقريبًا مساحة جغرافية
تم النشر عبر «واس» ولم يتم النشر عبر مؤثرين أو حتى صحف أخرى
ومن ثم تم تداول هذا الموضوع مطار أبها
وتم التعليق عليه، وتم الاحتفاء به، وبالتصميم وبالسعة
كل هذه تمت عبر الإعلام الرسمي لخبر رسمي يهم المواطن بالدرجة الأولى
ومن ثم يهم السائح والزائر بالدرجة الثانية
أظن في ناس راح تختلف معك في موضوع أن...
يمكن «واس» استثناء
لأن «واس» عندها نقطة قوة مهمة، أنها مصدر مباشر للأخبار
فالخبر يبدأ من عندها، وهذا بحد ذاته ميزة تنافسية غير عادية
لكن ماذا عن القنوات اللي تحت هيئة «الإذاعة والتلفزيون»؟
أزعم أنها لا تشبه كثير من الأجيال الجديدة
ولا تأخذ جزء من اهتمامهم ووقتهم
وهنا راح يجيء سؤال
أيش تحدي هذه الأجهزة في أنها تقدر تنافس؟
أيش التحدي اللي يواجهها حتى تنافس
وتأخذ من الوقت اللي اليوم قاعد يصرفه المشاهد السعودي في منصات ثانية؟
التحدي أعتقد أنه كبير جدًّا لأي وسيلة إعلامية
وليس له علاقة بالقنوات الرسمية
تجربة الـ«إس بي سي» جميلة تحصد مشاهدات جيّدة في...
لفئات عمريّة معيّنة، ولكن حتى لا نبالغ
في دراسة لمعهد «رويترز» بالتعاون مع جامعة «أوكسفورد»
كل سنة يخرجون أو يصدرون دراسة عن الإعلام تفصيلية
وعن توجهات الإعلام المستقبلية
يتحدثون عن أن 2023 ستكون أكثر سنة يعاني منها الإعلام في العالم
لأن الأجيال الجديدة لم تلتفت حتى لتويتر والفيسبوك
وإنما اتجهت إلى منصات مثل سناب شات وتيك توك
التحدي الحقيقي أنك تتواجد في تيك توك
التحدي الحقيقي أنك تتواجد في سناب شات
بمحتواك لا تتنازل عن الرصانة، ولكن تلامس
اليوم أحد المنتجات اللي أخرجتها فترة كورونا عن طريق وزارة الإعلام
مثلًا كان «قناة ذكريات»
و«قناة ذكريات» لامست الأجيال القديمة والحنين
وكل شخص يشاهد، والله هذا المسلسل الذي شاهدته قبل فترة
وهذا المسلسل الكرتوني
وأصبحوا يتداولون المقاطع بجودة عالية بعيدًا عن اليوتيوب
مسألة أنها لا تمثل أو تمثل الجيل الجديد
أصعب شيء ممكن تقوم فيه أي منصة إعلامية
سواءً رسمية أو غير رسمية هي مخاطبة فئة الشباب
أكثر من 70% من سكان المملكة العربية السعودية
أقل من خمسة وثلاثين سنة
هؤلاء احتياجاتهم مختلفة
وهل هذا الإعلام الرسمي اللي حكينا عنه يخاطبهم وللا؟
ما فيه اي إعلام في العالم قادر على مخاطبتهم
عدا البرامج التي تستهويهم في فترات محددة في أوقات معيّنة
اليوم عشان أقول لك الواقع
أكثر مسلسل مُشاهَد في السعودية تعرف أيش هو؟
لا والله
«شباب البوب»
مليارات المشاهدات على اليوتيوب
لكن هل هو فعلًا يمثل كل شريحة الشباب، وهل هو فعلًا مستهدِف؟
لكنه هو مسلسل مؤثر
لا تستطيع أن تقول: أنه ليس مؤثر
في شخص ممكن يطلع يقول: معقولة هذا إعلامنا وإنتاجنا؟
لا هذه رغبات شخصية وحريات شخصية في المشاهدة
اليوم نتفليكس وشاهد موجودين
الدوري السعودي اليوم، إذا تقول على الإعلام الرسمي
الدوري السعودي ما تقوم به قنوات «إس إس سي»
مع التحفظ على انقطاع البث أحيانًا في وسط مباريات مهمة
أيضًا هذا إعلام رسمي
عن طريقه يتم الاستحواذ على ساعات مشاهدة كبيرة للشباب
فموضوع تلبية الرغبات أمر صعب جدًّا
هو مو تلبية رغبات أبو محمد بقدر ما أنه الوصول إلى توقعات المشاهد
أنت الآن ضربت مثال بموضوع الإعلام الرياضي
أزعم بأنه نجحنا في أن نوفر منتج غير عادي اللي هو الدوري السعودي
بالنجوم واللعيبة الموجودين فيه
المباريات صارت ممتعة بشكل...
الواحد حتى مباريات الفريق اللي ما يشجعه قاعد يتابعها
لكن النقل التلفزيوني ما هو قاعد يواكب هذا الحراك
احنا من بعد الـ«إيه آر تي»
أتوقع ما في ولا تجربة وصلت لذائقة المشاهد
مو بالضرورة أذواق وآراء بقدر ما أنه في حد أدنى من الجودة
ينتظره المشاهد ما هو قاعد يلقاه
الجودة موجودة، أيضًا أنا عندي تحفظ على موضوع انقطاع البث
مثلًا عندي تحفظ على موضوع أن مثلًا مواطن سعودي
جودة الإخراج
مواطن سعودي
دقة الصورة
سواءً يعمل أو مُبتعَث في الخارج لا يستطيع المشاهدة
بسبب أنك إما أن تشاهده عن طريق تطبيق شاهد
والآن بسبب الحقوق الموزعة
جغرافيًّا
وهذا أمر جميل، أنك أنت أصبحت تُبَث في أكثر من 142 دولة
في موضوع تنظيمي مقلق ومزعج
أنك لا تستطيع المشاهدة بجودة عالية
إلا بلغة البلد اللي أنت فيه
لكن نقل التلفزيون يتطور، وجودة الصورة تطورت
الأخطاء التقنية ما زالت...
تتابع الدوري الإنقليزي؟
أتابع الدوري الإنقليزي
هل تشوف المقارنة؟
هل في تقارب في جودة النقل للدوري السعودي والدوري الإنقليزي
على «بي إن» مثلًا؟
هذا المقياس، هنا السعوديين راح يقارنون
ما هي فكرة تطورنا أو تحسنا
لا صراحةً، موضوع الجودة في التصوير وفي الكاميرا
إلى حدٍ ما نعتقد أنها متقاربة نعم
لكن الإخراج ممكن يختلف والتعليق
لما نتابع الدوري الإنقليزي المعلق يعلق تعليق مقتضب جدًّا
عمر ناول الكرة لعضوان، وعضوان سجل
في بعض المعلقين العرب يلقون قصائد شعرية في وسط المباراة
فيمكن يختلف في موضوع أسلوب التعليق والتكتيك
العالم العربي مع أمريكا اللاتينية يتشابهون في التعليق والصراخ
في الدوري الإنقليزي أنا أعتقد أنه هادئ إلى حدٍ ما
لكن نرجع ونقول: أن موضوع المقارنة بأن الإعلام الرسمي أو غيره يُمثّل
أو يلبّي رغبات شبابه، ويستطيع اقتطاع، دعنا نقول...
أن يصل لهم، ما هو قادر يصل لهم
أنا أعتقد أنه أمر صعب صدقني
فيستسلمون، المفروض ما أحد يركز عليهم؟
لا ما تستسلم، الآن هم قاموا ببرامج تستهدف الشباب
سواءً برامج مسابقات لها علاقة بالاستثمار
أو حتى برامج اكتشاف مواهب عن طريق الـ«إس بي سي» ونجحوا فيها
والقادم أجمل، إن شاء الله
لكن هذا أمر يخص وزارة الإعلام أن تتحدث فيه
لكن أنا أرى أن هناك جهد لا يجب التقليل منه
لو تأتي لكعكة الإعلام السعودي كاملة سواءً الرسمي
عارف أن بنروح للغير الرسمي
لكن أنا أعتقد أنه من أكثر الإعلام جودة
أنا أبغاك بس أنت اليوم تشوف القنوات السعودية
وطريقة الجودة في التصوير والتقنيات المستخدمة
وتقارنها، باختر عشوائيًّا من ست وسبع دول عربية فقط
لا نذهب إلى أوربا أو إلى دولة سبقت العالم العربي بـ200 أو 300 سنة
في الإعلام والصحافة
ستجد أنك متقدم بشكل مخيف جدًّا
بس حتى المقارنة هذه ما هي سليمة، اسمح لي أختلف معك
اليوم احنا في كل مستهدفاتنا ما احنا قاعدين نقارن نفسنا بالعالم العربي
أنت تقول: ما في مستهدفات في الإعلام؟ وهذا دليل جيّد...
في كل قطاعات، المقارنة المعيارية، في السياحة...
انا أتكلم على موضوع الإعلام الرسمي، والنقل التلفزيوني لما جئنا قارننا
وقلت لك: أنه لا يقل جودة على موضوع الدوري الإنقليزي
أو على أي دوري في العالم
بس اللي أقصده
أن اليوم في خطة السعودية كل القطاعات لما تضع مستهدفات
هي ما تنظر للمنطقة، مع الاحترام لكل اللي في المنطقة
هي سقف الطموح أن نكون من الأفضل على مستوى العالم في كل قطاع
في السياحة راح تلاقي المستهدفات مربوطة بأفضل التجارب العالمية
ما هي التجارب الإقليمية
فلما نجيء للإعلام المقارنة صراحةً والطموح
ما هو أن نكون أفضل إعلام رسمي بين الدول العربية
لأن التجارب ما هي مميزة للأمانة
مافي إعلام رسمي للدول العالمية
الخليج كله
لما أنت تقول لي: ما في مستهدفات هذا شيء إيجابي
لأن هذا ينفي وينقض ما يقولونه الناس: أن الإعلام مدعوم ومُوجّه
جميل جدًّا، أنه الإعلام ليس مستهدف من مستهدفات الرؤية
لأن الإعلام يطوّر نفسه بنفسه، ويطور أدواته بأدواته
لكن لما تجيء تقول لي عمر: أن الإعلام الرسمي
نريده أن يكون على مستوى العالم
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية مثلًا من القنوات الرسمية المعروفة «سي سبان»
«سي سبان» هذه القناة هي التي تنقل بث مباشر
لجميع المؤتمرات الحكومية وغيرها
في بريطانيا الـ« بي بي سي»
الـبي بي سي تصنيفها حكومي وغير حكومي
ولكن هي في الأخير حكومية
وتحصد مشاهدات عالية، وتركيبة الـبي بي سي مخيفة
تخيّل مثلًا أنت في نجران، في قناة «بي بي سي نجران»
موجود في تبوك، في «بي بي سي تبوك»
موجود في الرياض، في «بي بي سي الرياض»
ولديها قناة موجهة للأطفال، ولديها قناة موجهة للشباب
وبرامج الطبخ الأشهر في العالم فيها
لكن المداخيل المادية للبي بي سي مخيفة
لأن كل مواطن بريطاني يدفع في السنة 140 باوند أو 145 جنيه إسترليني
ما يقارب 700 أو 800 ريال سعودي، اللي هي قيمة اشتراك الكابل
عندك تلفزيون في البيت
يجب أن تدفع 800 ريال سواءً تشاهده أو لا
مجرد أنك عندك تلفزيون في منزلك تدفع 800 ريال
800 ريال هذه تذهب إلى هيئة الإذاعة الملكية البريطانية
والـبي بي سي تُصنَّف على أنها إعلام رسمي وغير رسمي
ولكنها تجربة ناجحة، ومن أنجح التجارب
لو أبي ألخّص هذا الجزء، سأقول: أنك أنت ترى فيه تطور، وراضي عنه
ومقارنةً بدول الجوار أنت تشوف أنه إعلام جيّد، الإعلام الرسمي
إذا قارناه بهذه المسميات، أنا أعتقد أنك أنت الأفضل
راح أروح للإعلام غير الرسمي، أول شيء الصحف أيش تُصنّف؟
إعلام رسمي وللا غير رسمي الصحف؟
«أم القرى» أكيد رسمي
«أم القرى» والبقية؟
مؤسسات صحفية، فيها مساهمين، ومجالس إدارات
فهي تعتبر إعلام غير رسمي؟
نعم
خلنا نكمل نفس الحوار في هذه المنطقة
أيش تقيّم أو أيش رأيك في الحراك في الإعلام غير الرسمي؟
من ناحية أي نقطة بالضبط؟
نبدأ بالصحف الورقية
ونقول: كيف حراك الصحف الورقية، ومواكبتها للمرحلة
في الخمس أو ست سنوات الماضية؟
تقصد مرحلة الرؤية ومرحلة...
إي
أولًا، الصحف، اليوم...
نحن ما زلنا بس نقيّم المشهد العام قبلما ندخل في كل قطاع
فتكلمنا على الإعلام الرسمية، الآن إعلام الصحف
أول شيء وجهة نظري يا عمر، أبو عبدالرحمن
أتمنى أني أنا أُوفَّق في طرحها للأمانة
هناك أساتذة ومخضرمين أكثر
والنعم فيك وفيهم
لكن أتمنى أني أنا أُوفَّق فيها
أولًا، الصحف دائمًا عليها ضغط أكبر، وعليها لوم أكبر
ولما تقول أنت: أنها تواكب التحول وتواكب التطور
هي الآن هناك صحف نجحت في موضوع التحول الرقمي
بدون ذكر أسماء، إذا تسمح لي
هناك صحف استطاعت مواكبة التحول الرقمي أو تحول العصر كامل
وأيضًا في تغيير الطرح
لأن الصحف كانت أكبر لاعب رئيسي في معركة الفكر السعودي
في معركة تمكين المرأة، وفي معركة التغيير الاجتماعي الحقيقي
حتى جاءت القرارات الشجاعة في عهد خادم الحرمين الشريفين
برؤية ولي العهد الأمير محمد بن سلمان
فيما يتعلق بالشباب وفي تمكين المرأة، وفي قيادة المرأة للسيارة
وكثير من التفاصيل البعض يراها أنها سطحية
ويراها أنها غير مهمة لأنها لا تهمه هو أو ليست من احتياجاته
لكن الصحف الورقية في عصورها الذهبية، كان لها عصر ذهبي
في كثير من الأمور الاجتماعية وفي كثير من النقد الداخلي
وفي كثير من ...
حتى كان لها أثر في تغيير
حتى لو كان شارع منزلكم أو شارع حارتكم غير جيّد
كان ممكن يكتب محرر متخصص في البلديات ويغيّر
وكان هناك صحف خاضت معارك كبيرة مع شركات الاتصالات، ونجحت
وكانت تتعرض لتهديدات بسحب الإعلانات إذا لم يتوقفوا عن هذا النقد
فالصحف الورقية عاشت عصر ذهبي قوي
بسبب انخفاض العوائد الإعلانية
وبسبب عدم مواكبة التحول الرقمي منذ بدايته
بعض الصحف تقهقر، وبعضها ما زال موجود
لكن أنا أعتقد أنها تؤدي دور
لا أستطيع أن أقول: قوي أو أستطيع أن أقول: ضعيف
ولكنها تؤدي دور جيّد
اليوم تؤدي دور هي؟
أنا أعطيك مثال، حينما جاءت أزمة كورونا
والآن في أي حدث يحدث سواءً في حرب غزة أو في كورونا
أو في كثير من الأحداث التي مرت على العالم، في حرب أوكرانيا
إذا أردت أن تشاهد أو أن تقرأ تحليل جيّد لا تذهب إلى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اذهب إلى مصدر إخباري رصين
الصحف المحلية تشاهد فيها أو تقرأ تحليل جيّد على أي موضوع
لكن أنا محتار ما أدري أيش أقول
قل الصدق، ما يحتاج تجامل
لا
أبو محمد أعطنا إياها بدون أي دبلوماسية زائدة
لازم الدبلوماسية
لا، فكّنا من الدبلوماسية
صعب
احنا بودكاست، وأمورنا سمحة، ما احنا مثلكم، أنتم رسميين وبروتوكولات
لا، ما احنا رسميين، وما في بروتوكولات
زي ما شرحت لك
إذا كانت في أزمة، وعاد الناس إلى الصحف لمتابعتها كمصدر
الصحف متسيّدة وأقوى
لأن دورة الخبر أصلًا تمر على خمس أو ست أشخاص
للتأكد من أن هذا الخبر خالي من أي إشاعة أو خطأ
والأخطاء تحدث والأخطاء واردة
لكن أنا أعتقد أن الصحف كأدوات قوية ولكنها كمحتوى
صعب التعميم، كثير منها محتواها ضعيف جدًّا
أنا بالنسبة لي لو بضرب مثال، أقول :يمكن أختلف معك في هذا الجزئية
وبالنسبة لي صحيح أن في الأزمات واللحظات المهمة
العودة دائمًا للمصدر الموثوق
والمصدر الموثوق اليوم بالنسبة لي ما هو الصحف
المصدر الموثوق بالنسبة لي اليوم الصحفيين المتخصصين
وين ينشروا؟
أيًّا كان نشره، بس أنا بالنسبة لي راح أتابع مثلًا في الشأن اليمني «بدر»؟
«بدر القحطاني» في «الشرق الأوسط»
«بدر القحطاني» ما أدري أصلًا وين يشتغل، بس أنا أتابعه في تويتر
احنا راح نجيء للصحف المتخصصة
راح أقرأ تحليلاته وراح أقرأ تغريداته في الشأن اليمني
وهي مرجعي الموثوق
ما أعرف وين يشتغل، ولا وين ينشر، ولا وين يكتب
فاللي أقصده أن قد أختلف معك، يمكن هو موظف في جهة رسمية لكن فعليًّا...
هو في صحيفة «الشرق الأوسط»
الأثر هو جاي أو الاتصال بينه وبين الجمهور
جاي من منصات العالم الجديد كصحفي فرد
وليس بسبب المؤسسة اللي خلفه، هنا مصدري أنا كعمر
أنت تعتقد أنه بهذه السهولة، لكن مع احترامي لك أنا أختلف معك أيضًا
تفضل
لولا...، طبعًا «بدر القحطاني» هو صحفي...
أنا ضربته كمثال وفي غيره كثير
إي، صحفي متمرس وزميل وصديق
لكن مثلًا لولا المنصة التي وفرت لـ«بدر القحطاني»
أن يصبح صحفي متخصص في الشأن اليمني
هل سينشر هذه المعلومات؟
حتى لما تعمل في مؤسسة مثل اسم «الشرق الأوسط» مؤسسة كبيرة عربيًّا
تعطيك المساحة للتواصل مع كثير من المسؤولين في اليمن
سواءً مع أو ضد
و«بدر» ما أود أن نضرب مثال محدد
لكن «بدر» أيضًا يتواصل حتى مع الطرفين
مع «الحوثي» ومع «الشرعية» ويأتي بقصة متوازنة
لأنه يعمل في مؤسسة رصينة
ولديها أعراف ولديها تقاليد، لكن اليوم «بدر» لو أتى بخبر عن اليمن
ممكن ينشر على حسابه في تويتر
خبر صحيح أو خبر كاذب، هذا أمر يعود إليه هو على مهنيّته ومصداقيّته
لا يمكن نشره في «الشرق الأوسط» حتى يتأكد مدير التحرير
ومساعد رئيس التحرير أو نائب رئيس التحرير
من جميع التفاصيل والمعلومات
خصوصًا إذا كانت أخبار حساسة، هذا الفرق
نفس الشيء أظن في صحفي رياضي برضو في صحيفة رياضية نسيت اسمه
لكن كان نشيط في فترة الانتقالات والصفقات
وأتذكر كان يسوي له إعادة تغريد كثير
فعرفت أنه يشتغل في صحيفة رياضية
فهل هؤلاء الأمثلة وغيرهم تخلينا نتخيل
أن دور المؤسسات الصحفية هي تصير أشبه بمكتب خلفي أو مطبخ
والنشر هو من خلال الصحفين الأفراد
هل هذا التطور الطبيعي للصحافة؟
ولا أيش تطور الصحف الورقية أو التقليدية في المستقبل؟
التطور الطبيعي للصحافة أنه كل صحيفة وكل مؤسسة إعلامية
يجب عليها صناعة نجوم وصناعة صحفيين متخصصين
وصناعة مواهب، وتأهيل نفسها لهذا الصحفي
لا قدّر الله، أخذه القدر أو انتقل إلى مكان آخر
يجب أن يكون هناك بديل
حتى في موضوع الصحافة المتخصصة
يمكن إذا نتحدث عنها لاحقًا إذا سمحت لي
مثلًا «اندبندت البريطانية» عندها «سايمون كالدر»
«سايمون كالدر» صحفي متخصص في السياحة
«الاندبندنت» تعرف بلا...
ما يدع مجال للشك أن «سايمون كالدر» قد ينتقل لمكان آخر
أو قد يتوفاه القدر
أتوا بصحفيّة أخرى منذ ثلاثة أعوام اسمها «هيلين كوفي» احتياط
وهي أصبحت من الصحفيين المبدعين في «الاندبندنت»
وقامت بجولة في أنحاء العالم في موضوع كورونا
فقد يكون للصحافة أو للصحف أو للمؤسسات الصحفية مكتب خلفي تؤهل
هذا لا يعيبها، بل واجب من واجباتها أن تؤهل...
أنا ما أذكره كعيب، أنا أقصد أيش مستقبل هذه الصحف؟
مستقبل الصحف أنها هي التي أخرجت هؤلاء الصحفيين
دليل أن الصحافة والمؤسسات الصحفية ما زالت هي البيت الحقيقي
لصناعة الصحفي الحقيقي وفق أعراف وقيم وأخلاقيات
لا يمكن أن تشاهد صحفي ينشر شائعة لأنه يعرف أن هناك من يحاسبه
وهناك رقابة ليست رقابة للسيطرة وإنما رقابة للفلترة
والمحافظة على المصداقية
فأنا أعتقد المؤسسات الصحفية جزء كبير من واجبها
بعض المؤسسات الصحفية لديها وبعضها لا يوجد لديها للأسف هذا الأمر
تأهيل القيادات واكتشاف مواهب
وتقديم مواهب متخصصة في جميع المجالات
خلني أقفل هذا الجزء بأني أسألك
أنتم بدأتم كصحيفة رقمية من اليوم الأول؟
وبدأتم جزء من مجموعة إمبراطورية إعلامية
ففيه فرص ومزايا مادية ومالية وتمويلية مختلفة عن غيركم
أيش أهم درس أنت كرئيس تحرير اليوم تعلمته
من المعاناة المالية والتحدي المالي
اللي تواجهه كثير من الصحف اللي ما هي قادرة تغطي مصاريفها
وقد تكون في يوم من الأيام خرجت من السوق
نتيجة عدم القدرة على الاستدامة المالية
أيش الدرس اللي أنت تعلمته؟
ومنتبه له من اليوم حتى ما تكون يوم من الأيام مكانهم؟
اسمح لي الإجابة على هذا السؤال صعب لأن صعب الحديث عن معاناة آخرين
هناك صحف تعاني، وهناك صحف استثمرت
أعطنا أمثلة ممكن؟
من اللي عانت، واللي استثمرت
صحيفة «اليوم» في المملكة العربية السعودية هي من أذكى الصحف
اللي استثمرت عوائدها الإعلانية في فترة الرخاء
وأعتقد لديهم برج استثماري أو مكتبي أو سكني
لا أعرف صراحة بالدقة، في المنطقة الشرقية
صحيفة ذكية، استهدفت سكان المنطقة الشرقية منذ اليوم الأول
في أخبارهم متخصصة في المنطقة الشرقية
قرّاؤها من أهالي المنطقة الشرقية
إعلاناتها في داخل المنطقة الشرقية
والمنطقة الشرقية كبيرة ومنطقة مهمة
أتوقع أن هذا أنجح النماذج في أمريكا، اللي هو الإعلام الإقليمي
أو المتخصص في مدينة أو ولاية معينة
هو الظاهر الإعلام اللي لسه عايش بشكل جيّد
الـ«إيه بي سي» نفسها لديها قنوات محلية داخل كل ولاية
والإعلام الإقليمي والمحلي
لأن أهل الحي يريدون معرفة التفاصيل
أهل الحارة يريدون معرفة التفاصيل
وأهل المدينة، وأهل الولاية يريدون معرفة التفاصيل
فكل ولاية لها إعلامها القوي
وأنا أعتقد حتى في بريطانيا هناك إعلام محلي أو إعلام للمدن
فصحيفة «اليوم» ذكية جدًّا، بدأت قبل سنوات قليلة
يمكن ثلاث أو أربع سنوات موضوع التحول الرقمي الكبير
وموضوع إنشاء مراكز تدريب
فأصبح لديها ملاءة مالية تستطيع الإنفاق، وتستطيع التطوير
وتستطيع الاستمرارية
فكان هناك استثمار ذكي في فترة رخاء
في فترة العصر الذهبي للإعلانات الورقية
حمتها من التعثر الذي حدث لكثير من الصحف
بسبب عدم استثمارهم في التحول الرقمي
أما بالنسبة للنماذج التي تقهقرت
هناك الصحف أُغلِقت لأنها أصلًا بُنيت على...
ليست دراسة جدوى استثمارية
لا أعرف لماذا ظهرت تلك الصحف؟
هناك صحف أُغلقت بعد سنوات من صدورها
وهناك صحف ما زالت مستمرة تعاني ماليًّا، تحاول تصحيح أوضاعها
أيش الدرس اللي أنت تعلمته، وأيش قاعد تتلافى؟
مواكبة العصر
شلون تواكبون العصر اليوم أنتم؟
أنا اليوم، وأعوذ بالله من كلمة أنا
عبر فريق قوي في «اندبندنت عربية» في جميع المجالات
بدأنا بإنتاج أفلام وثائقية، وبدأنا بمحاولات خجولة في موضوع البودكاست
وبدأنا بموضوع الصحافة المتخصصة في مجالات معينة
بدأنا بتنويع النشر
ليس نشر فقط إلكتروني لخبر أو تحقيق أو مطوّلات
وإنما بجميع أنواع الوسائط الموجودة احتياطًا
لأي مستقبل ممكن أنك تستثمر فيه
تستطيع الاستثمار عبر الوثائقيات
وتستطيع تقديم نفسك كـ«اندبندنت عربية»
بأنك لست موقع إلكتروني إخباري فقط، وإنما تجمّع إعلامي
أنا أستطيع أن أذهب إلى الشركة، وأستطيع أن أذهب إلى الشخص
لإقناعه بأنني قادر على إنتاج متعدد لما يريد
فأنا أعتقد أول شيء مواكبة العصر في هذا الموضوع
التحول الرقمي للأسف مرتبط عند كثير من المؤسسات الصحفية
بأنه يجب أن لديك حسابات في تويتر والفيسبوك وموقع إلكتروني فقط
وكثير من الصحف
لما نتكلم كثير من الصحف حتى في العالم العربي ليس في السعودية
تقوم بتغيير موقعها إلكتروني، ومن ثم تنسف الأرشيف كامل
لا يهمها الأرشيف، يهمها الشكل الخارجي، ويهمها جودة الخط
ويهمها أشياء تفصيلية لا علاقة لها بالواقع الحقيقي
وهو الأرشيف الذي بُنيَت عليه هذه الصحيفة
التحول الرقمي، ودراسة احتياج السوق، ومعرفة سلوك المستهلك
وإعلانات موجهة لهؤلاء
ومحاولة أيضًا زيادة عدد القراء عبر صحافة متخصصة
لا يمكن لصحيفة محلية أن تنافس صحيفة سياسية
لا يمكن لصحيفة إقليمية أن تنافس صحيفة دولية
فهم التخصص في المهمة التي أُنشِئت لها
فأنا أعرف ماذا تريد «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
من «اندبندنت عربية»؟
ولماذا أُنشِئت «اندبندنت عربية»؟
ولماذا تم التعاقد مع «الاندبندنت» الأم؟
ولماذا تم الاستثمار فيها؟
هناك من يحاسبك، وهناك رئيس تنفيذي، وهناك رئيس مجلس إدارة
وهناك منظومة كاملة تعمل فيها بتوافق ما بين التحليل والإدارة
وتعرف ما لك وما عليك، وتحاول تفادي الأخطاء
وتحاول الاستشارة، وتحاول الاستفادة
ولسه احنا ما إلنا أربع سنوات وثمانية أشهر، إن شاء الله، والقادم أجمل
هذا مدخل على الجزء الثالث والأخير في تحليل الواقع أو تحليل المشهد
اللي هم المؤسسات الإعلامية العملاقة
أو الامبراطوريات الإعلامية العملاقة
يمكن أشهر تجربتين هي تجربة مجموعة الـإم بي سي
وهنا يمكن أكثر شاهد بالنسبة لي أبغى أسمع رأيك فيه
هو شاهد نفسه
منصة شاهد هي بالنسبة لهم التحول الرقمي، ومواكبة العصر الجديد
فودّي أسمع منك عن هذا الموضوع
و«المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
اللي فيها حراك مكثف جدًّا الفترة الماضية
الاستحواذ على جزء كبير من «ثمانية»
استحواذ على مؤسسات إعلامية والشراكة مع مؤسسات إعلامية عالمية
«الشرق بلومبرق» وإطلاق قرارات اقتصادية
«شرق بلومبرق» و«شرق ديسكفري» و«اندبندنت بيلبورد»
حراك غير عادي
فأيضًا ودّي أسمع رأيك في الحراك اللي صاير في هذه المجموعتين
أنا أرجع، وأقول: رأيي الشخصي
أكيد
شاهد كان تحول قوي وذكي لأنه من الظلم لأي مؤسسة إعلامية
أن تقوم بإنفاق الملايين أو مئات الملايين من الدولارات أو المليارات
ومن ثم هناك مشاهد يأخذ هذا المحتوى بشكل مجاني
وينتقد المحتوى، وينتقد المؤسسة الإعلامية
فموضوع الدفع أنا أعتقد أنه أمر طبيعي
لكن أنا ما أعرف كم عدد مشتركين شاهد
هل وصلوا ثلاثة مليون أو تجاوزوا ثلاثة مليون في العالم العربي؟
أنا ما أعرف صراحةً، كم العدد؟ العدد ما زال في نمو
ولكن أعتقد أن مجموعة الـإم بي سي
لديها مشكلة في موضوع الحقوق الملكية الفكرية
أن كثير من الناس يقوم باختراق شاهد
أو حتى بنشره مجانًا أو بيع حسابات معينة
وهذه أزمة في العالم العربي كاملًا، موضوع الحقوق الفكرية
حتى لو أنا اليوم قمت بفرض رسوم على الاشتراك
حتى في «اندبندنت عربية» أو في «الشرق الأوسط» أو في أي مكان
قد يأتي شخص متبرع فاعل خير يقوم بعمل لقطة شاشة، ونشرها مجانًا
فهناك أزمة في موضوع الحقوق، لكن تجربة شاهد ذكية
وجاءت في وقت لم يكن هناك منصات تقوم بهذه التجربة، وما زالت تنمو
هل ستحافظ إم بي سي على موقعها الريادي؟
إم بي سي ما يختلف أحد أنها رائدة إعلام التلفزيون
في العالم العربي لفترة طويلة
الزمن قاعد يتغير
هل اللي أنت تشوفه اليوم في إم بي سي
قادر أن يخليها تستمر في ريادتها للإعلام المرئي؟
أول شيء تتفق أنها هي رائدة الإعلام المرئي؟
نعم
هل ستحافظ على هذا الموقع؟
الإعلام السعودي هو رائد الإعلام العربي، عشان نختصر الموضوع
وحتى لو كان البعض يراه وجهة نظر متطرفة
باستثناء الإعلام الرياضي
الإعلام الرياضي في العالم العربي؟
إي
دوليًّا أو عربيًّا؟ نتكلم دوليًّا؟
دوليًّا أو عربيًّا
بي إن سبورت هي رقم واحد في موضوع الإعلام الرياضي الدولي
وهي بُنيَت على أخطاء السعودية فيما يتعلق بـ«أوربت» و«أيه آر تي»
أنت لديك التجارب الرائدة، وأنت صاحب السبق تخطئ فيها
نعم، ويقوم الآخرين ببناء نجاحاتهم على أخطائك، وحتى الجزيرة
الجزيرة أساسًا كانت قناة «بي بي سي العربية» اللي أخذت السعودية وكالتها
فكثير من المذيعين والمذيعات فيها انتقلوا
والقصة معروفة لا داعي لتكرارها
لكن أخشى المجموعة السعودية تعتب أني جالس أحكي عن تجربة الإم بي سي
تجربة الإم بي سي الرائدة التلفزيونية هي رقم واحد في العالم العربي
لا يستطيع أحد منافستها في مجال الأخبار العربية
وفي المجال الدرامي وفي مجال المنوعات الإم بي سي
أنا أعتقد أنها رقم واحد ولا يمكن أبدًا منافستها من الآخر
وعندك «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام» أيضًا رائد في موضوع الأخبار
وفي موضوع المطبوعات
وأيضًا الآن دخلت في مجال التلفزيون لأول مرة في عام 2020
عبر قناة «الشرق» وليست قناة «الشرق» شبكة «الشرق للأخبار»
وأصبح تحتها «الشرق وثائقية»
والجميع يعرف أن للأسف مع كل هذه القوة الإعلامية السعودية
لم يكن لدينا قناة وثائقية طيلة العقود الماضية
فقناة «الشرق الوثائقية» أول قناة وثائقية متخصصة تعتبر سعودية
بعدها بأسابيع إطلاق «الشرق ديسكفري»
وهذا أعتقد أنه أيضًا يعتبر أمر ذكي
وخطوة ذكية وتفكير في المستقبل
فإذا أتينا لموضوع الإم بي سي في الريادة العربية
لن يستطيع منافستها أحد
وإذا أردنا «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
فهي تستحوذ تدريجيًّا على حصص مشاهدة عبر شبكة «الشرق الإخباريّة»
لكن أيضًا أعتقد أنه لا يمكن منافستها
فيما يتعلق بالمطبوعات والصحافة المكتوبة
ما دام ذكرت موضوع القنوات
يمكن أنا ما وجدت أي شخص يتفق مع فكرة القنوات الجديدة
في قناتين مؤخرًا بدأت، ومع أني أنا أعتبرها تجارب مميزة
أنا شفت القناة «الثقافية» وشفت «بلومبرق الشرق»
كلا القناتين فيها عمل رائع جدًّا بس أظنه متأخر
متأخرة جدًّا فكرة القناة
حاولت أسأل المحيط حقي، ما أظني لقيت أحد يتابع القناتين
مو لسوئهم بس لأنه ما عاد أحد يتابع تلفزيون
فودّي أسمع رأيك في خطوة أنك تفتح قنوات تلفزيونية
في عام 2022 وعام 2023
هل ما زال في مجال لهذه القنوات؟
أول شيء جرب، ما أنت خسران شيء
أجرب أيش؟
افتتاح أو تدشين أو إطلاق
لكن إذا أنا صراحةً كان ودّي أعلّق على كل...
لكن لا، أنا ودّي أن نركز على «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
في عام 2016 في صحيفة بريطانية طلعت
وأُصدرت جلست تسع أسابيع وأُغلقت
اسمها «ذا نيو داي» كانوا يستهدفون 400 ألف للتوزيع
بعدين خفضوا سقف التوقعات لـ 200 ألف
بعد تسعة أسابيع من الإصدار أُغلقت هذه الصحيفة
ما جاء أحد وفتح هاشتاق، قال: إعلامنا لا يمثلنا وسيء
ولا جاؤوا ناس يهاجمون الإعلام البريطاني
ما في مهاجمة، بس الكلام عن أنه متأخر
أنا أتكلم أنه عادي أتت تجربة وأُغلقت، أمر بسيط جدًّا
بالنسبة لـ«شرق الوثائقية» تتحدث عنها أو «الشرق» بشكل عام؟
بشكل عام كل قنواتهم التلفزيونية
لا أنا أعتقد أن «الشرق» كان هناك حاجة لإطلاقها
أولًا من المؤلم أن المملكة العربية السعودية دولة اقتصادية قوية
ضمن مجموعة العشرين
وموجودة من المؤسسين «الأوبك» ومن المؤسس الأساسي «الأوبك بلس»
لا يوجد لديها قناة اقتصادية، واحد
ثانيًا، الشراكة مع «بلومبرق» أنا أعتقد أنها مهمة
و«شبكة الشرق» كما قلت لك: كان الأساس منها «الشرق بلومبرق»
ولكنها أصبحت متعددة الأذرعة، ليست متأخرة أبدًا حتى القناة «الثقافية»
أنت اليوم كل هذا الحراك
ولديك وزارة الثقافة أكثر من اثني عشرة هيئة تندرج تحتها
لا يوجد لديك منصة تجمع كل هذه
والمحتوى اللي جالس يُضَخ أكبر من خيالنا
«الأوركسترا السعودية»
«الأوركسترا السعودية» في نيويورك وفي باريس، ومعارض الكتب
كل هذه الفعاليات والأحداث الثقافية...
أنت شايف لهم فرص نجاح القنوات هذه؟
صعب الحكم صراحة، تأخذ وقتها والمشاهد يحكم
لكن المهم أن يكون هناك هدف من الإطلاق، وليس الإطلاق لأجل الإطلاق
أنا أرى أن شبكة «شرق الأخبار» كان هناك حاجة لإطلاقها
وتحديدًا في الجانب الاقتصادي
ستستحوذ في وجهة نظري على نسب مشاهدة تدريجيّة أعلى
اليوم المشاهد لا يشاهد التلفاز، ولكن يشاهد التطبيقات المرتبطة بالتلفاز
شاهدت محبةً صراحة في القناة لأن أتابع «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث»
دخلت على قناة «الشرق الوثائقية»
وشاهدت أكثر من 40 مليون مشاهدة تقريبًا
لما بُث على اليوتيوب حتى هذه اللحظة
وهي لم تمضي عليها شهر ونصف تقريبًا أو شهر
البعض يقول: رقم كبير أو رقم قليل
لا أنا أعتقد أنه رقم كبير لقناة لم تبدأ أصلًا
تحتاج على الأقل سنة أو سنتين أو ثلاث حتى تحكم عليها
ومع ذلك انطلقت لأرقام كبيرة
المجالات مفتوحة، والبقاء للأفضل، والبقاء للمتجدد وليس للأقوى
البقاء للأكفأ والمتجدد، والساحة تتسع للجميع
وما يزال هناك فرص لم تُستَغل حتى هذه اللحظة
يمكن القاسم المشترك بين الكيانين اللي تحدثنا عنهم
واللي هم عندهم موقع ريادي في العالم العربي
إم بي سي و«المجموعة السعودية» أنهم ينتمون لمرحلة تاريخية ماضية
وسولفنا أنا وإيّاك
وكنت تسميها أنت الفترة الذهبية للإعلام السعودي أو المرحلة الذهبية
أيش هي المرحلة الذهبية للإعلام السعودي؟
المرحلة الذهبية للإعلام السعودي، الدولي؟
نعم
المرحلة الذهبية للإعلام السعودي
هي في الفترة اللي يكون فيها الإعلام السعودي هو الـ...
أتكلم على المداخيل المادية
لكن إذا تكلمني على الفترة الذهبية فترة تأسيس الإم بي سي
ويتحدث عنها مُلّاك الإم بي سي و«المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
تخيل أن كل الدول العربية
ولا أبالغ وتحديدًا النفطية سواءً خليجية أو غير خليجية
حاولوا استنساخ التجربة السعودية في الخارج وفشلوا
صدام حسين حاول منافسة «الشرق الوسط» وفشل
هناك من حاول إصدار أكثر من صحيفة في الخارج لمنافسة الصحف السعودية
مجلة «المجلة» و«الشرق الوسط» وفشلوا
حتى في عام 2016 و2017
صدرت بعض الصحف وللأسف ماتت قبل أن تُولد أساسًا
فالإعلام السعودي...
دائمًا يُربَط الموضوع بالملك «فهد» الله يرحمه، والملك سلمان، الله يحفظه
أن كان لهم دور مهم في تمكين الإعلام اللي اليوم هو في موقع ريادي
أيش تعليقك على الموضوع؟
والله فيه أساتذة كبار يتحدثون عن هذه الفترة
أنا شفت لقاءك مع الأستاذ «وليد إبراهيم، أبو خالد»
وتحدث عن هذه الفترة أيضًا
هناك أساتذة قد يتحدثون عن هذه الفترة أكثر
هم عايشوها وعاصروها، وبدأوها أيضًا
الأستاذ «عثمان العمير» والأستاذ «عبدالرحمن الراشد»
قد يتحدثون عنها بشكل أكبر
لكن الرؤية بعيدة المدى للملك فهد، رحمه الله
والملك سلمان، حفظه الله، لما كان أمير الرياض
هي في أنه لا يوجد لدينا صوت في الخارج
أعتقد أن الأفكار بدأت بالتبلور
ومن ثم أصبحت «الشرق الأوسط» هي «الشرق الأوسط»
و «إم بي سي» هي «إم بي سي»
واليوم بعد كل هذا الوقت
أكثر من أربعين وأكثر من خمسة وأربعين سنة
أعتقد على «الشرق الأوسط»
كانت هذه الرؤية في محلها
اليوم لا يستطيع أحد منافسة الإعلام السياسي السعودي
ولا أحد يستطيع منافسة الرياضة التلفزيونية لمجموعة «إم بي سي»
وكانت هي برؤية منذ عقود
قصص مختلفة للمجموعتين
مجموعة الإم بي سي قصة مختلفة تمامًا في فكرتها وتأسيسها
وقصة «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
ولكن ما يميز الإعلام السعودي صراحة
أو حتى رأس المال السعودي حينما يكون على أساس
ويكون عنده رؤية ويكون عنده هدف
هو المستمر والمستدام حتى هذه اللحظة
كثير من الدول حاولت تدخل في مجال الإعلام السياسي، ومن ثم تراجعت
كثير من الدول تميّزت سنتين أو ثلاثة أو أربع سنوات، ومن ثم تراجعت
المؤسسات الإعلامية السعودية ما زالت تحافظ على رصانتها
وأتحدث عن الإعلام الخارجي
لا يوجد...
تخيل من أفكار بسيطة اليوم
لا يوجد منزل عربي، ودع من يقول: صيغة مبالغة أن يثبت العكس
لا يوجد منزل عربي لا يوجد فيه مطبوعة
من مطبوعات «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
منزل عربي يختلف مع السعودية أو يتفق معها
وهذا الاختراق الناعم الذكي
ولا يوجد منزل عربي لأي دولة عربية تتفق وتختلف مع السعودية
لا يوجد فيها منتج تلفزيوني تابع لمجموعة الإم بي سي
معادلة بسيطة جدًّا
هذا هو الانتشار وهذا هو التأثير، وهذه هي القوة
فهو كان كانت فترة ذهبية في تلك الفترة لأنه كانت فترة القراءة القوية
وفترة المداخيل الإعلانية القوية وفترة التأثير الحقيقي
ما كان فيه وسائل تواصل اجتماعي
ولا كان في موقع إلكتروني يحرق عليك الإنتاج الذي تنتجه غدًا
فكان حتى «الشرق الأوسط» التي كانت تُباع لفترة قريبة بثلاثة ريالات
تحس أنك أنت من النخبة حينما تقوم بشرائها
كانت تُشتَرى، وكانت تنتهي الأعداد في السوق
لأنه كان عصر ذهبي سواءً لها أو للصحف الورقية الأخرى
ما زال هناك عصر ذهبي موجود للإعلام الدولي
والسعودية متسيدة في هذا المجال
وأيضًا في المجال الدرامي، ما أعرف تختلف تتفق عمر أنا...
أنا هنا بحرص أن أسأل الأسئلة أكثر من أني أعبر عن رأيي
لا عندك وجهة نظر دائمًا تتفق وتختلف
لا أنا راح أروح للي بعدها، وهي نقطة جدًّا مهمة
وكانت أكثر الأسئلة اللي وصلتنا من الأصدقاء
أصدقاء أو قصدك أصدقاء البرنامج؟
أصدقاء البرنامج
أنا توقعت أصدقاء عمر
لا، هم أصدقائي أصدقاء البرنامج
لا، أصدقاء «سقراط» وأصدقائك الشخصيين
أظن في هذا الجزئية تحديدًا كلهم يتفقون
فيه دائمًا استفسار على موضوع مساحة النقد في المرحلة الحالية
اليوم، البعض، وما أظنه قليل وإنما يمكن كثير
يعتقدون أن مساحة النقد في الإعلام السعودي تقلصت
وهذه تُربَط بالمرحلة الحالية بشكل أساسي
أبغى أسمع رأيك فيها، هل هذا صحيح؟
أولًا وبعدين...
نقد لأيش بالضبط؟
نقد موضوعي لمختلف أعمال الجهات الحكومية
اليوم يمكن أن السبب الأساسي صعوبة التواصل مع الجهات الحكومية
لكن نعم هناك انخفاض للسقف، نعتقد أنه أمر طبيعي جدًّا لأسباب كثيرة
اليوم كان هناك دولة
أو السعودية لم تكن بهذا الحراك الاقتصادي والتنموي
تحت أي ظرف من الظروف ولا الاجتماعي حتى
وهناك أناس يجلسون على الطرف الآخر
ينتظرون أي نقد أو انتقاد لتضخيمه وتهويله
في الإعلام السعودي ما كان أساسًا النقد الموجود مُوجَّه للأجهزة السيادية
أو للشخصيات الاعتبارية
وهذا خط أحمر لا يوجد مزايدة فيه، ولا يوجد مزايدة عليه أبدًا
فننتهي من هذا الموضوع
متفقين
حتى لا نبالغ، ولا نحمّل الإعلام ما لا يحتمل، هذا واحد
ثانيًا: هناك انتقاد وهناك نقد يحدث وُفق الحالة
لكن تأتي لمعركة مثل يمكن ذكرتها قبل قليل
كان في زمان معركة بين شركة «الاتصالات السعودية» وصحيفة «الوطن»
معركة كسر عظم في موضوع الرأي، واستمرت لفترة طويلة
فكل النقد اللي كان يدور في الصحافة هو نقد على إما الخدمة
أو الخدمات اللي تقدمها الوزارات وبعض الجهات
أو على الشركات الكبرى مثل: شركات الاتصالات أو الخطوط السعودية أو خلافه
أنا ما أعرف أيش هو السبب؟ لكن ما أعتقد أن فيه قيود
وأنا أقول: أعتقد أني أعرف ما أقول
لا يوجد قيود على الصحف أنها لا تنشر
ولا يوجد قيود على الصحف أنها لا تنتقد هذه الشركة أو تلك
ولا يوجد قيود على الصحف أنها مثلًا لا تتحدث عن الخدمات المقدَّمة
بالعكس من فترة للأخرى، حتى شاهدنا أتذكر في صحيفة «المدينة»
كان هناك انتقاد لـ«الخطوط السعودية»
ومن ثم انتقاد أيضًا للمرور، أمر طبيعي الانتقاد
لكن هو انخفاضه
أنا أعتقد أن الصحف تتحمل جزء كبير، والجو العام يتحمل جزء كبير
فأنت تقول: نعم في انخفاض، والمسؤول هي الصحف نفسها
إلى حدٍ ما
ما مارست دورها؟
مش ما مارست دورها
أحيانًا يكون في رقيب ذاتي في عقل رئيس التحرير أكثر من اللازم
ما أعتقد أن في أي جهة
دعنا نقول: في «الهيئة العامة لتنظيم الإعلام» أو حتى وزارة الإعلام
تمنع انتقاد خدمات معيّنة كما كان في السابق
لأن الصحف السعودية في فترتها اللي تحدثت عنها في صراعات فكرية
كان هناك تجاذب فكري قوي، وكان هناك تطرف، وكان هناك انفتاح
كان هناك محاولة لفرض وصاية على المجتمع
وكانت الصحف تدفع لرفض الوصاية على المجتمع
في المقابل كان هناك انتقاد على كثير من الخدمات
كان انتقاد على موضوع مراجعة للجهات الحكومية والدوائر الحكومية
ما أعرف هل هو فرض برضو نقدر نقول: أن انخفاض الحالة بشكل كبير
أو أن الخدمات تطورت إلى درجة ما عاد في شيء تنتقده
لكن لما حصل في تغيير «خطوط السعودية» لشعارها وعودتها للقديم
كان هناك انقسام في الآراء
وأعتقد كثير من الصحف نشرت عن هذا الأمر
بس نحتاج لمتخصص يدرس الحالة
في صحيفة انتقدت الشعار الجديد؟
اطلعت أنت على أي صحيفة انتقدت الشعار الجديد؟
«اندبندنت العربية»
أنتم انتقدوه؟
نعم، لا انتقدناه ولا أثنينا عليه، كتبنا توصيف الحالة
انقسام الآراء حول عودة «الخطوط السعودية» إلى شعارها القديم
لا نبالغ في موضوع أنه، قد يكون فيه انخفاض للسقف قليلًا
لكن أيضًا لا يوجد مبادرات من رؤساء التحرير للحديث عن ما يحدث
وطبعًا لا أعمم
وكما قلت لك أيضًا: قد يأتي شخص ويقول: لا
كثير من الخدمات التي كانت يتم انتقادها
سواءً في عدم القدرة على الحجز
وسواءً في الانتظار الطويل لحتى يتم الرد على مكالمتك
من جهة حكومية وإلى آخره، انتهت بموضوع الخدمات الإلكترونية
فكثير من المشاكل انتهت، وكثير من الأزمات انتهت
واليوم أنت في ورشة تنمية تحديثية كبرى
نتائجها ما زالت، بعضها ظهر، وبعضها لم يظهر
الجزيرة اللي قمت بتغطيتها
إن شاء الله، نروح معك بعد انتهاء الجزر الأخرى
ما تقدر تنتقد شيء أنت ما شفته، ولا تقدر تنتقد شيء ما نُفّذ
فأعتقد أن هناك مشاريع تنموية كبرى تتم
ولا تنسى أيضًا أنك أنت إلى وقت قريب كنت في حالة حرب
و لا أبالغ إذا قلت لك: أن كثير من الدول في العالم
إذا كانت في حالة حرب
الانتقاد يختفي بشكل كامل، ويتم التركيز أيضًا على السلم
توحيد الصفوف
توحيد الصفوف، وعلى السلم وعلى...
في جميع الدول سواءً أوربية أو في أي جزء من العالم
أنت اليوم كرئيس تحرير، تكون مثال جيّد نقدر نكتشف فيه
أيش هي طبيعة العلاقة مع المؤسسة الرسمية أو الجهات المشرفة على الإعلام
كـ«هيئة تنظيم الإعلام» أو كوزارة إعلام وإلى آخره
هل يُراجَع العمل اللي تنشره من قبلهم؟
هل يصير فيه ملاحظة أو طلب حذف أو طلب تعديل من الجهات الرسمية؟
أولاً، صعب أني أنا أضرب بنفسي مثال
ما لنا إلا أنت، الباقيين ما نقدر نعرف الجواب منهم
لا، اسألهم، واعملوا استبيان
عمر، ما في جهة رسمية تقول لك: لا تنشر
ما في؟
مافي رقابة أصلًا، كانت في شخصية من أفضل الشخصيات
اللي حللت المشهد الإعلامي والمتخصص في الصحافة
«محمد القشعمي، أبو يعرب»
ولديه مؤلفات صغيرة جدًّا، لكنها منوعة في الصحافة
في وقت من الأوقات في المملكة العربية السعودية
كان هناك رقابة على الصحف قبل النشر
لا تستطيع، طبعًا قبل أربعين سنة أو أكثر
فهو أرّخ للصحافة السعودية
نعم، كان هناك نظام للرقابة والنشر في وزارة الإعلام
قبل أربعين أو خمسين سنة، لا تستطيع النشر حتى تُجاز الصحيفة
اليوم هذا الشيء مو حاصل؟
لا يوجد تمامًا
قد طُلِب منك حذف محتوى؟
لا أبدًا، ممكن ترد ملاحظة...
على فكرة ما ودي أصدمك لما تكون تشتغل في صحيفة عربية ودولية
الانتقاد أو طلب الحذف والتعديل ما يجيك من بلدك، يأتيك من دول أخرى
عجيب
نعم
أنتم بما أنكم مهتمين بالشأن العربي أكثر من الشأن المحلي؟
الشأن العربي والدولي
أذربيجان قدمت في تغطية للحرب بين أذربيجان وأرمينيا
طلبوا بتعديل أمر معين، فكان هناك وجهتي نظر في الموضوع
فطلبوا أن مراسل «اندبندنت عربية»
يقدموا له دعوة يزور الحدود ويشاهد الوضع كما هو
هذا دليل أنك مؤثر، الحمد لله
وليس «اندبندنت عربية» أتكلم عن الإعلام
أنا ما زلت أتحدث عن الإعلام السعودي، وأنه مؤثر عربيًّا ودوليًّا
فتخيل أن أذربيجان تهتم بصورتها، وتطلب من المراسل
أو من الصحيفة أن تُرسل أو تُوفِد مراسل
حتى يشاهد الأمر على أرض الواقع، هذا أمر جيّد
هناك دول عربية تنتقد أو تطلب تصحيح معلومة معينة أو حدث، فالحمد لله
تكتشف أنك مؤثر، ولا تريد خسارة الجميع
كيف توازن بين...؟
لكن أنا أرجع وأقول: لا يوجد رقابة قبل النشر
بس في رقابة بعد النشر؟
الرقابة بعد النشر، شوف ما يُطلَب منك الحذف، أنا ما أتكلم عني
أنا أتكلم لا يُطلَب منك الحذف، يُطلَب منك تصحيح الخبر
تصحيح الخبر تستطيع أنك أنت تضيف....
نسخة معدلة
إيوة، في دولة خليجية رفعت علينا قضيتين وخسرتها في...
واحدة من القضايا خسرت قبل أن تبدأ
والقضية الثانية انتهت قبل أن تبدأ
والسبب أنه كانت جميع وجهات النظر منشورة و...
خطكم التحليل أنتم؟ كل خبر عندكم لازم تنشرون وجهتي النظر صح؟
تحت أي ظرف من الظروف، ما يمكن نشر أي خبر
إلا فيه وجهتي نظر وفيه المصدر وفيه الاسم
حتى شخصية
رجل أعمال لبناني رفع قضية وشكوى، وطلب تعديل، وطلب حذف النص
وأن الشركة التي ذُكِرت في الخبر هي شركة تابعة له، كان فيه جدل
فكان فيه رد وأخذ عن طريق المحامي
التابع لـ«المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
حتى وصلنا إلى حل وسط أنه لا يوجد حل وسط
أن الخبر كان مدعّم بكل التفاصيل، ولكن كانت مبالغات من محاميه أعتقد
لحذف أو لتعديل، ولم ينتهي الخبر بحذف ولا تعديل
بس أنا أتخيل اليوم أنه كصحيفة مموّلة
من مؤسسة إعلامية سعودية أو شركة سعودية
إلا ما يصير في لحظة معينة أنك أنت تقع في النص
بين أنك أنت تنشر الخبر اللي قد يخلق أزمة سياسية بين بلدين
وبين أنك أنت تستجيب للتوجه السياسي اللي ما يبغاك تشارك
في هذا الموضوع أو في هذه القضية
تمر أكيد بهذا النوع من النزاع وللا لا؟
إذا خبر وللا مقابلة راح تسويلك أزمة بين السعودية ودولة أخرى
ستنشرها؟
لما أزمة بين السعودية ودولة أخرى، أنت أعطي فرصة للآخر للرد
كثير من الدول تعترض بعد النشر
بعد النشر؟
ما يدرون أيش راح تنشر، لكن بعد النشر يتم الاعتراض أمر طبيعي
تُعطَى مساحة لتبيان وجهات النظر الأخرى
الصحافة معقدة، والصحفي يمشي على حقل ألغام
الصحفي الذكي هو من يعرف كيف يتراقص على الخطوط الحمراء لا يتجاوزها
قد انفجر فيك لغم؟
الحمد لله، بس بدون خسارة...
أطراف
الحياة سعيدة، تمشي والصحافة جميلة، وممارساتها جميلة
قناة «الشرق» قناة مطلقة حديثة، السقف فيها مرتفع
والطرح اللي يُطرَح فيها طرح قوي جدًّا، وسقفه مرتفع
صدقني، المحاولة هي أكبر برهان وإثبات
حاول وانشر، ومن ثم إذا أتاك الاعتراض، انشر وجهة النظر المعترض بها
أو التي تريد تصحيح الخبر أو المعلومة أمر طبيعي
نحن اليوم زي ما قلنا: لو نمر على كل حلقات «سقراط»
راح نلاقي أنه كل قطاع يعيش قصة تحول جذرية وشاملة
قطاع الإعلام فيه حراك، بس ما هو واضح، أيش هو المشروع...؟
على الأقل لي أنا، يمكن للآخرين واضح لهم
أيش هو المشروع السعودي في قطاع الإعلام؟
تقدر تتخيل أو توصف لنا، أيش هو مشروعنا؟
إي، المشروع السعودي في قطاع الإعلام بشكل غير رسمي وللا بشكل رسمي؟
اعطني إياه كله
الرسمي شرحنا
وتحدثنا على القنوات التابعة لـ«هيئة الإعلام المرئي والمسموع»
وشرحت لك الحراك الموجود و«مركز التواصل الحكومي» وإلى آخره
أنا أعتقد أن التوجه، عندك ثلاث مجموعات إعلامية...
أنت ما أعرف ليش حسيت روتانا عندك مشكلة معهم؟
لا، أبدًا ما في أي مشكلة
بلعب دور الصحفي
عندنا ثلاث مجموعات إعلامية «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
وأتشرف أني أعمل فيها وأفتخر، هي الأكبر في مجال النشر
وعندك مجموعة الإم بي سي، وعندك روتانا
هل هي فرسان رهان؟
أعتقد، هذه الثلاث مجموعات الإعلامية هي الأكبر في العالم العربي الآن
وأعتقد أن المستهدف يجب أن تكون أنها الأكبر على مستوى العالم
على مستوى العالم؟
لو تقرأ الإحصائيات المتعلقة بمداخيل القنوات العالمية تُصدَم
تخيل مذيعة أمريكية «كيتي كروك» راتبها 10 ملايين دولار، سنويًّا أعتقد
عقبالي وعقبالك
آمين
ومداخيل البرنامج سنويًّا «ذا ديلي شو» 250 مليون دولار، شوف الرقم
أتكلم على ميزانية خمس صحف ورقية أو أكثر
في كل المحاولات السعودية الحالية أنا أعتقد من المؤسسات الكبرى
أنها تصل إلى مرحلة متقدمة لا في المداخيل المادية
ولا في التأثير ولا في الانتشار ولا في القوة
أرقام...، ما زالت في العالم العربي
مهما حصل أن الإعلامي يرى نفسه مؤثر ومشهور
تخيّل أن إحدى المذيعات الأمريكيات بدل اللبس بس 2 مليون دولار سنويًّا
تخيّل أن مداخيل نيويورك تايمز الرقمية فقط عام 2020
400 مليون دولار، تخيّل
فأنا أعتقد أن المجموعات...
فالمشروع السعودي هو الرهان على هؤلاء الثلاثة فرسان
اللي هم قاطعين شوط؟ الكلام عليهم هم
أعتقد أنها تتحول لمؤسسات...
هي لأنها مؤسسات عربية هي المؤهلة الوحيدة
الثلاث مؤسسات هي المؤسسات المؤهلة أنها تصبح هي عربية فتصبح عالمية
سواءً عبر الاستحواذات أو سواءً عبر الشركات أو سواءً عبر الاندماج
لا أعرف ما هو المستقبل لها
لكن السعودية باختصار في جميع المجالات
كانت المارد النائم وتحرك
فطبيعي أن الإعلام أيضًا هو مارد نائم، ويتحرك
و«المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام»
اللي عملته في السنوات القليلة الماضية
سواءً من استحواذات أو من الشراكات أمر مخيف
كانت تتربع على عرش عدد من الأسماء الكبيرة في الشرق الأوسط
مجلة «المجلة» و«سيدتي» و«هي» و«الرجل» و«الاقتصادية» و«الرياضية»
أكثر من ثلاثين اسم الآن
تملكه «المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام» وتستثمر فيه
تحركت في أربع سنوات
استثمرت في ما لم تستثمر فيه طيلة العقود الماضية
فأنا متفائل، وأنا أرى أن الإعلام السعودي هو الأبرز والأقوى
ويجب عدم تحميله أكثر مما يحتمل
إذا أتيت لكل ما أُسِّسْ عليه الإعلام السعودي
هو لمخاطبة الجميع بلغة متزنة وبلغة رصينة
ولهذا هو يستمر وغيره من إعلام الشعارات يسقط
لو شاهدنا حتى في الأحداث الأخيرة في غزة
إذا أردت أن تشاهد تغطية متزنة
تجد فيها جميع الأطراف ستشاهد قنوات ...
بس الشعوب ما تبغى كذا ولا لا؟ مو هذا اللي يبيع
اللي يبيع...، عربات الطعام في الشارع تبيع
لما أنت تتحول من مؤسسة صحفية رصينة
إلى مؤسسة ما يطلبه المستمعون أو المشاهدون ستنتهي
لأن هذا المشاهد سيتغير رأيه غدًا، وستتغير ذاقته غدًا، ومن ثم سينتهي
فأنت مؤثر بشكل مخيف جدًّا، وستكون مؤثر بشكل أكبر
ويجب علينا أن نتفاءل، ويجب علينا...
لما أقول: يجب علينا، ما أقول: ادعموا الإعلام السعودي
وقولوا الإعلام السعودي...
الإعلام السعودي تعرض لهجوم مخيف جدًّا من الآخر
مما هو خارج السعودية
وهذا لأنك أنت مؤثر، الشرق الأوسط...
بس الهجوم مو فقط من الخارج حتى من الداخل
حتى الداخل يشوف أن الإعلام السعودي ما يمثله
وما هو مواكب للمرحلة وللا لا؟
يمكن هذه نشوة في وقت معين
لما تفهم دور الإعلام تجد أنه يمثلك
لكن لما يكون في فهم أن الإعلام هو من يجب، مثلما تحدثنا في بداية الحلقة
أنا لما أغلق السياحة، وما عندي تأشيرات السياحيّة
ومن ثم يأتي شخص أمريكي يكتب على تويتر كلام مسيء
كيف أنا ممكن أدعوه، وأتحاور معه؟
هذا ما هو دور الإعلام
هذا دور المؤسسات الأخرى اللي تفتح مجال السياحة
وتقوم بالترويج، وتقوم بأمور أخرى
كما قلت لك: نرجع لموضوع الدفاع عن الوطن واجب علينا جميعًا كأفراد
حتى كمؤسسات، حتى الدفاع بشكل مباشر وغير مباشر
لكن الإعلام السعودي تعرض لهجوم مخيف جدًّا
العربية يسمونها العبرية، الذي أطلق عليها هذا اللقب حزب الله
وصف الإعلام السعودي بأنه يتسم بالخطاب المُتَصهين
أطلق عليها هذا الموضوع مجموعة من الإخوان المسلمين
«الشرق الأوسط» حينما كانت في الثمانينيات تقوم بدور قوي جدًّا
في محاربة التطرف
وفي تعرية الإخوان المسلمين أطلقوا عليها «خضراء الدمن»
صحيفة «الوطن» إذا بتأتي على الشأن المحلي، الوثن
كل الذين يطلقون عليها هذا الأمر هم قلقين منها
ويتعرضون لتعرية بسببها
فلازم أحاربها، ولازم أضرب مصداقيتها، ولازم أحارب من فيها كذلك
فتخيل أنك أنت تهاجَم سواءً في الداخل أو في الخارج لأنك تشتغل صح
الناس فاقدينك أبو محمد في موضعين، هذا من ضمن أسئلة الأصدقاء
يقولون: فاقدينه في مشاركات القنوات الأجنبية
كان عضوان فعّال في القنوات الأجنبية
للدفاع عن السعودية، وتمثيل وجهة نظرها بشكل مميز
ومدعوم بالحجج والبراهين، وبطريقة مشرفة
أحيانًا البعض، الله يهديه، يطلع وتقول: ليته ما طلع
هذا ما ودّك أن يدافع عنك، بعض الأشخاص
أنت دائمًا دفاعك كان مدعوم بالحجج، لكنك وقّفت مؤخرًا ما عاد نشوفك
والموضع الثاني اللي فاقدينك فيه، ما عاد تشيطن الإعلام الجديد
رضيت عنهم وللا سكت عنهم، وللا جلدوك، وللا أيش السالفة؟
أبدأ بالأولى وللا بالثانية؟
اللي تبيه، خذ راحتك
لا انت اختر
وين فاقدينك الناس؟
ما في مشاكل، أنا أطلع وقت المشاكل بس
والحمد لله، إن شاء الله، ما في مشاكل
وجهة نظرهم صحيحة لكن أنا متواجد
قبل عشرين يوم تقريبًا أو أقل مع «فرانس توينتي فور»
على موضوع وجهة نظر السعودية فيما يتعلق بغزة
طبعًا وجهة نظري الشخصية
يمكن أقرأ ما بين السطور أحيانًا بتوفيق من الله
لكن تحدثت عنها بثماني دقائق
وقلت ما هو موجود في، سواءً على الأرض
شلون تحضر لهذا النوع من اللقاءات؟ لأن عادةً تكون ساخنة
خلصنا موضوع الإعلام صح؟ ولا باقي أسئلة الناس الآن؟
دخلنا على أجزاء منها، وراح نروح ونجيء، فاخذ راحتك، سواليف هي
الأمر سمح
أحضر، حتى مقابلتك محضّر لها
لا أنا سمح،أنا وش حليلي، لكن أقصد...
حتى لما تقابل لا تسخر من أحد، ولا تستهتر من أحد، مش أنت، أي أحد
تقول: والله عمر راح يسولف معي، خلاص أروح أنا ما فكرت، أيش راح يقول؟
لا، أحط أسئلة متوقعة...
بس في حدود واضحة أنها راح تكون موجودة في هذا الحوار
وفيه حدود غير واضحة
لما تطلع في صحيفة أو في منصة أو قناة أجنبية معروفة بحدة طرحها
وراح يكون معك زميل آخر شرس
وعنده هجوم حاد اتجاهك، وقد لا تُعطى مساحة الرد
وما تدري أيش راح يرمي عليك من تهم؟
وتضيع أنت بين تمثيل نفسك، وتمثيل رسمي للدولة
شلون تحضر لهذه الأجواء اللي فيها وقت محدود؟
وما تدري أيش نوع الطرح اللي راح يُطرَحه؟
لأنك أنت أحيانًا تضرب أمثلة تخترق فيها الطرف الآخر بنماذج وشواهد من بلده
وللا من المرجع حقه
فودي أعرف كذا بس من باب الفضول
شلون تحضر لتلك اللقاءات الساخنة؟
هذا اللقاء بارد وحليل، فما هو مقياس
لا، هو أي لقاء آخر فيه أسئلة متوقعة
أنا إذا دُعيت من «فرانس تونتي فور» أو من بي بي سي عربي
أو من أي قناة، أحط من عشرة إلى خمسة عشر سؤال متوقع
طيب لو سأل على كذا أيش راح أقول، ولو الضيف الآخر...؟
على فكرة بعضها أربع أو خمس ساعات قبل اللقاء
فما فيه، ما أتذكر قناة كلمتني قبلها بيوم قالت: الله بكرة
إيوة، لا قبلها بأربع أو ثلاث ساعات
أحاول أطرق الأبواب ما أحد يعطيني وجه
أتكلم على مسؤولين أنه طيب في الموضوع الفلاني، فهي اجتهادات شخصية
فما يكون فيه تنسيق مع جهات رسمية
لا أبدًا، بالعكس
اجتهاد شخصي
أتذكر، أنا عندي في الواتساب، مجموعة العائلة وإلى آخره
فأرسل أحيانًا أن الليلة البرنامج الفلاني...
إذا قبل الحلقة بيوم علّمني عشان أرسل، قبلما تسوي الإعلان
ففي مسؤول صديق أرسل لي
قال لي: ما أنصحك تتكلم عن الموضوع الفلاني
لأنه موضوع حساس، ويمكن يزعلون
شكرًا، بعد اللقاء قال لي: شكرًا لك، بيَّض الله وجهك
شكرًا أنك تكلمت؟
شكرًا أنك وصلتها بطريقة غير مباشرة
أنت ما نفّذت مشورته هذا المقصد صح؟
لا بالعكس، ما هو ما نفّذت مشورته، أنا هذه تربكني
لو أنت مثلًا يا عمر قلت: والله أنا بطلع الليلة
سوّي كذا وقول كذا ولا تقول كذا، أنا راح أرتبك
فمخي يتبرمج على لا يزعل أو لا يرضى
لكن لما أنا أعرف أنه في مهمة للدفاع عن الوطن
وأعرف أن الوطن مهاجَم في هذا الموضوع
التحضير مهم، ومعرفة مداخل على الضيف مهمة
والوقت ما في إلا أربع ساعات
فعندك ساعة أو ساعتين تقرأ عن الموضوع
وعندك ساعة تحضر للشواهد اللي ممكن تستخدمها لاستفزاز الآخر إذا استفزك
والنقطة الرابعة هي في محاولة مشاهدة لقاءات سابقة للضيوف
أنا أسأل، ما يعطونك أسئلة، هو سيقول لك: نتكلم على مثلًا
موضوع وجهة النظر السعودية فيما يحدث مثلًا
ثم يجيب لك شخص من إسرائيل، وشخص من فلسطين، وأنت موجود
فعلى الأقل أبغى أعرف شخصية الشخص أو نفسيته في اللقاءات كيف
أو أيش أبرز الأشياء اللي يدور حولها دائمًا؟
وتوفيق من الله، سبحانه وتعالى، والحمد لله
أنا أعتقد الدفاع عن الوطن غير أنه شيء واجب على الإنسان
أحيانًا يكون مصدر محبة، وكثير من الناس قد يحبوك لهذا الشيء
وتشعر بالفخر لأنك كنت على شيء صحيح
وتقوم بالدفاع على الوطن بشكل جيّد
اللي قد يُفقِدك المصداقية على الهواء
حينما تدافع بشكل فجّ، وتشتم الآخر
وتُسقِط على الآخر وتعاير الآخر، وتكون عنصري مع الآخر، وتمنّ على الآخر
لا تمنّ، ولا تعاير، ولا تصبح عنصري، ولا تنفعل، ولا تحتقر، ولا تستهين
بالعكس عامل الناس كلهم في مستوى معين، وفي مرحلة معينة
بالعكس عاملهم أو توقع أنهم أقوى، وأفضل منك
حتى تشعر أنه يجب عليك الوصول لمرحلة معينة
من إقناع المشاهد، وليس إقناع الضيف
فدائمًا أي شخص يظهر في أي لقاء تلفزيوني
المفترض أنه يخاطب المشاهد
لا يخاطب لا المذيعة أو المذيع، ولا يخاطب من هم موجودين على الطاولة
ويمكن في حركة يسوونها البعض
ما أعرف ممكن أنا أسويها أو ممكن ما أسويها
لا تستمع لكلام الضيف
لا تستمع؟
لا تستمع لكلام الضيف، قل ما تريد، اسمع ولا تستمع
اسمع أيش يقول، ولكن لا تستمع له
لا يدخل في مخك، ويخربط أفكارك اللي ستقولها
فأنت تصير محضر كلام معين راح تقوله بغض النظر أيش الضيف؟
لا، بالعكس أنت لازم ترد عليه
أحيانًا يقول وجهة نظره أنت صححها، بس أنت اسمع كلام، بس لا تستمع له
لا يربكك الكلام، ولا توجّه الخطاب له مباشرة
مثلًا لو أنا وإيّاك على طاولة وحدة وعمر تكلم عن السعودية بشكل سيء وإلى آخره
ما أقول: أنا أقول عندي وجهة نظر ودّي أقولها
بس بقول: الضيف الكريم مثلًا قال: كذا
بس أنا أخاطب المذيعة أو المذيع وأخاطب المشاهد
لأن هي لها جانب نفسي أعتقد أنها ستصل
والإعلام الجديد، رضيت عنهم، وصالحتهم؟
ما عندي مشكلة معهم يا عمر، أنا ما عمري انتقدتهم
أنا أنتقد الجهات الحكومية اللي تستعين فيهم
لا أنت انتقدتهم نقد حاد في حتى تغريدات عندك
أن فلان طلع اسمه «أبو وعل» ...
لا يمكن ذكرت...
أنت استخدمت رمز معيّن
أن أيش؟
«أبو وعل» اشتهر في مقطع في سناب شات
بكرة راح يجي يعطينا محاضرات عن الإعلام الجديد والقديم
أنا ما قلت: «أبو وعل» من «أبو وعل» هذا؟
أنت عندك التغريدة هذه في 23 أغسطس، 2016
«هناك نجم جديد قادم بقوة في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اسمه «أبو وعل»
بعد أشهر وبعد تجاوز متابعينه مليون سيُستَضاف للتنظير في الإعلام الجديد»
فأنت تقول: أن كل الإعلام الجديد
«أبو وعل» شخصية افتراضية؟ والله ما أعرف الموقف
هو شخصية افتراضية، مو شخص حقيقي
أنا شوف يُستَضاف، أنا ما قعدت أقول أنه... هو سيُستَضاف للتنظير
أنا عندي مشكلة مع، للأسف أنه كلهم زميلات وزملاء وصديقات وأصدقاء
اللي يعملون في مجال الإعلام الجديد، وموضوع الإعلام الجديد فيه فرق
بين الإعلام الجديد اللي هو الإعلام الإلكتروني والصحّافة الجديدة وإلى آخره
ولا قصدك أنت المؤثرين ونجوم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي، حدد؟
مين الإعلام الجديد؟
الإعلام الجديد هو...
يشمل هاذان الاثنان كلّهم؟
الإعلام الجديد هي الوسيلة
وأيضًا الإعلام الجديد قد يكون في تقديم الخبر بشكل جديد وبقوالب جديدة
أنا ما عندي مشكلة مع المشاهير
ولا عندي مشكلة مع المؤثرين، صدقني
ولكن عندي مشكلة مع تسطيح القضية ومع تسطيح الموضوع
وأنا عندي مشكلة أيضًا مع الجهات الحكومية
التي غير قادرة على تطوير نفسها، وللا تطوير أدواتها
فتقوم بضخ كل ميزانياتها الإعلامية للاستعانة بمشاهير للترويج لها
يا أخي خلينا نفعّل خيال مش الخيال العلمي
تخيل بكرا والله تويتر قرر إيلون ماسك يطفي تويتر
قال: أنا ثري جدًّا، وعندي 44 مليار دولار ما أبغاها مع السلامة تويتر
أرشيف الجهات الحكومية...
فهمت المقصد
وتخيل أيضًا أن شركة سناب شات أفلست وأغلقوه
كجهة حكومية وين منصتك الأساسية؟
هل موقعك الإلكتروني كامل وقوي؟
لأن المعادلة مختلفة عندنا بس في العالم العربي
لكن اليوم لما يكون أي مواطن بريطاني أو أمريكي
يريد السفر إلى أي دولة
يذهب إلى موقع وزارة الخارجية لمشاهدة تحذيرات السفر على هذه الدولة
وما هي المحاذير التي يجب أن يتفاداها، وما هي التعليمات؟
هل هي دولة آمنة؟ إلى آخره
موجود في موقع وزارة الخارجية السعودية
لكن اليوم كثير من الجهات الحكومية أصبح لديها إدمان المشاهير
وهذا يدفعها مستقبلًا إلى عدم القدرة على كتابة محتوى جيّد لمواقعها
وكثير من الجهات الحكومية، وأنت عارف
أنها تستعين بشركات لكتابة نصوص ومحتوى
هذا النص والمحتوى من الذي يكتبه؟
هل هو شخص عمل في مجال الإعلام والصحافة، وتسلسل وتدرج؟
ويعرف ما هي المحاذير؟ ليست المحاذير في مسألة خطوط الحمراء
لكن هذه الجهة ماذا تريد؟
أم أن أنا عندي موقع جديد إلكتروني لأي وزارة من الوزارات والهيئات
وأنا أريد أن أتجه لمجموعة كتّاب محتوى
وأوقع مع شركة كتابة محتوى
هذه الشركة مستعينة بمجموعة من الشباب والشابات
ما أعرف الأخطاء الملائية من اللي يصححها
ممكن عندهم مدقق لغوي بدوام جزئي
العملية مكشوفة والعملية واضحة
فالأزمة هي مع الجهات الحكومية، وليست مع المغرد، صدقني
ولا مع المؤثر، كلهم أصدقاء وأعزاء ولهم التحية والتقدير
تجمعني بهم صداقات وروابط مشتركة
لكن أنا أقول: الجهات الحكومية يجب عليها تهيئة نفسها لأي عطل إلكتروني
تخيل كابل بحرية الإنترنت في العالم أُغلِقت
بس هؤلاء الإعلاميين الجدد اللي هم إعلام الفرد
صحافة المواطن يسمونها
هذه هل لها مستقبل؟ اليوم كثير من الجمهور قاعد يتجه لهم
حتى لو افترضنا بأنه في وقت كورونا راح ثلاثة أيام يرجع للصحافة الرسمية
هو عنده 360 يوم في السنة يستمع ويتابع هذا الفرد
وخصوصًا اللي تمكنوا من أن يقدموا نفسهم كمتخصصين في قطاعات معينة
وفي مجالات معينة
هذا النوع من الإعلام...
كيف يقدم نفسه متخصص في مجال معين
وهو يقوم بالحديث عن خمس مجالات في اليوم
بمبلغ مدفوع كيف؟
هذا الإعلان
هو هذا الشخص يقدم نفسه على أنه متخصص؟
نعم
ما يمكن أني أنا أقدم نفسي على أني متخصص، وأنا أتحدث في خمس مجالات
ترى ما تحدثنا على الصحافة المتخصصة صراحة
ياريت، خذ راحتك
لكن لاحقًا إذا تسمح لي
ما أقدر أنا أتكلم في خمس مواضيع في نفس اليوم
وفي خمس مجالات مختلفة
في السياحة وفي مكافحة المخدرات وفي «أوبك بلس»
وفي الكرة وفي الموسيقى ما أقدر
ما في شخص أصلًا عاقل يعملها، فالإعلام الجديد عملها
أو إعلام الفرد اللي أنت تقول: عملها
لأن المهم له هو الدخل، والمهم للجهة هو الترويج
فاتفقت المصالح، ولكن بدون وجود بحث
ما في ولا نموذج بالنسبة لك مرضي فيها؟
في كثير والله من الشباب، صعب أني أحصر أسماء
في كثير من الشباب متخصصين في مجالات، أبدعوا فيها
هل تتوقع لهم تطور واستمرار
لهم مكان في مستقبل الصحافة ومستقبل الإعلام؟
أتمنى أنهم يستمرون، هو المشكلة في عدم الاستمرارية
لأنه جهد فردي؟
ما هو جهد فردي، هو يبدأ بجهد فردي، ويبدأ بالإخلاص لهذا الجهد الفردي
وبعدما يصبح لديه متابعين يبدأ بحصد الإعلانات
وبترك الأساس الذي هو بُني عليه
وأعتقد أنك تتفق معي فيها
أظن هذا سيناريو يتكرر في كثير من الحالات
أنا أتابع كلنا نتابع، أقول: والله أنا عمر الجريسي، أضرب فيك مثال كنوع من الـ...
إذا هو مدح تفضل، إذا مو مدح راح أقصه
صحيح من عام 2015 و2016 و2017
وأنت متخصص في موضوع الاقتصاد المحلي
بعدما أُطلقت الرؤية
بدأت أنت باليوتيوب بمحاولات بسيطة، ومن ثم في سناب شات
واليوم أي شخص يريد الحديث عن مشاهدة مشاريع الرؤية
أو التسلسل اللي حدثت فيه الرؤية، عمر الجريسي
تخيل بكرة أنا أتابع موضوع مثلًا «جزيرة سندالة»
وألاقي عمر الجريسي في مطعم بروستد
أنتظر السنابة اللي بعدها، والله عمر الجريسي راح يسوي دعاية للقهوة
طيب يا رب راح يتكلم؟ متى راح يتكلم على الموضوع؟
وبعدين عمر الجريسي والله ما نزل تغريدات اليوم
أو سنابات على موضوع الرؤية
حسنًا ممتاز، الأسبوع اللي بعده
عمر الجريسي مسافر رحلة مدفوعة الأجر إلى جزيرة خارج السعودية
عبر شركة طيران، طيب عمر الجريسي متى؟
بعد سنة من حصد الإعلانات
يأتي عمر الجريسي يحدثنا بثلاث دقائق عن هذا الموضوع
فطبيعي أنك أنت تعمل إلغاء متابعة
فالحالات هذا الفرق بين الصحفي وبين الناشط المؤقت
أن الصحفي متخصص مهني يبحث عن استدامة أكبر
لأن هذه مهنته وهذا شغفه والشغف الحقيقي للصحفي ليس البحث عن المال
الشغف الحقيقي هو شغف المهنة
ممكن أنا أقتبس كلام لـ«بتال قوس» قاله في حلقة «فنجان» قبل كم أسبوع
يقول: «المرحلة تتسم بالنشاط الصحفي الهائل
الذي يفتقد لكثير من قواعد المهنية»
أيش رأيك في الوصف هذا؟
كلامه صحيح، هو نشاط صحفي ونشاط معلوماتي ونشاط إعلامي
أحيانًا تغطيات وأحيانًا تقارير
على فكرة يأثر حتى على العقل والدماغ
أنا أتمنى أن «عبدالرحمن أبو مالح» أو برامجكم المتخصصة في أمر
أو حتى ممكن تستضيف أحد، عمر، له علاقة بموضوع برمجة الدماغ
عقلك اليوم ما صار يستوعب كثير من المعلومات
بسبب ضخ المعلومات اللي تتعرض له يوميًّا
تتعرض إلى ضخ معلوماتي مخيف، حتى كثير من البرامج في السابق
حتى القنوات الفضائية كانت محدودة وعددها محدود
وتعرف أنت أيش راح تشوف اليوم الساعة 10، وتعرف متى تنام
اليوم أنت كل مرة تحطها في المفضلة، والله بشوفها بعدين، ما تقدر
فأنت في نشاط هائل، ولكن لا يوجد قواعد مهنية، هذا واحد
لأنه هو نشاط فردي
فالنشاط الفردي لا يمكن تقيّده برئيس تحرير ومدير تحرير
ورئيس قسم يقوم بالتعديل، لا، نشاط فردي، أنا أخذ الجوال وأروح
أتمنى ما تعتبرون بثوث التيك توك الغير الأخلاقية جزء من...
مو صحافة هذه؟ ما هي بإعلام جديد؟
هذا جزء من النشاط الموجود
هل تعتقد أن عزوف الناس عن الصحافة أو عن الإعلام
أو عن التلفزيون الرصين أو حتى عن المسلسل الرصين
وإدمانهم لما يحدث في التيك توك، أمر مبشر بالخير؟
أكيد لا، ولا له علاقة بالإعلام، وأمر محزن ومؤسف
وهذا بسبب عدم وجود بدائل أقوى استطاعت إبقاء هؤلاء لديها
أنا أختم بمحور، وبعدين أروح إلى أسئلة الأصدقاء
اللي هو موضوع الإعلام المتخصص
أنت كان عندك شيء ودّك تقوله في هذا المجال؟
الإعلام المتخصص، ليش أقول لك: لما جاءت «الشرق بلومبرق»
جاءت في مساحة ما في أحد في الصحافة الاقتصادية
تحدثنا باقتضاب في البداية
عدد الصحفيين المتخصصين في النفط في السعودية
لا يتجاوز أصابع اليد الواحدة، مش اليدين، اليد الواحدة
وأتمنى من...
وهذا غريب في الدولة الأكثر تأثيرًا على أسواق النفط العالم
مش الأكثر تأثيرًا، أنت من مؤسسين «الأوبك» وأنت مؤسس «الأوبك بلس»
وأنت تقريبًا المتحكم باقتصاد النفط في العالم
عدد الصحفيين المتخصصين في النفط لا يتجاوزون أصابع اليد الواحدة
أتمنى من المحللين النفطيين لا يخرجون، ويقولوا: لا والله احنا أكثر
لا، أنا أتكلم عن الصحفي المتخصص في مجال النفط
ليش هذا المشهد؟
ما أعرف، المؤسسات الصحفية تتحمل جزء...
في ناس يقولون: أنه لأنه كانت فترة أرامكو مغلقة
أنا أقول لك: المؤسسات الصحفية تتحمل جزء
المؤسسات الصحفية مهما اجتهدت لا يوجد لديها بيانات مفتوحة
فيما يتعلق بالنفط والطاقة
ما زال في وقت صراحةً لتصحيح...
اليوم اختلفت القصة، اليوم أرامكو شركة مدرجة
بغض النظر عن أن أرامكو شركة مدرجة لكن الصحافة النفطية
ما في صحفي متخصص...
أقصد عذر عدم توفر البيانات اليوم نُفِيَ
وإلى الآن ما عندك صحافة متخصصة في قطاع الطاقة
ما عندك صحافة متخصصة في قطاع الطاقة
ما عندك صحافة متخصصة في قطاع السياحة
عندك صحافة متخصصة في قطاع الرياضة
الصحافة الفنية جاءت فترة في السعودية كانت أقوى من غيرها
لكن ما زال، كل هذه أنا أعتقد...
والمستقبل للصحافة المتخصصة وللا لا؟
الصحافة المتخصصة تستطيع حصد...
سواءً تخصص في مجال أو تخصص في نطاق جغرافي؟
النطاق الجغرافي
وللا الحجم ما يحتمل هنا؟
لا، يحتمل، تخيل أنك أنت صحيفة تصدر من جدة
وتخصصت في شؤون جدة، وأهالي المنطقة الغربية، ستنجح
وكثير من المؤسسات الصحفية قد تستطيع إعادة تموضوع مثل هذا الأمر
وأنا أعتقد أنها ستنجح
أنا سأقيسها على أصدقائك اللي تحبهم اللي هم الإعلانيين
عندهم توجه رهيب في موضوع الحسابات المتخصصة
واحد صاحب مطعم في حي «عرقة»
يقول: مرة جبت واحد من أشهر اللي في سناب شات
ودون ذكر اسم
والإعلان عنده كان بـ60 ألف ريال، سوّى إعلان للمطعم حقي
اليوم الأول امتلأ المكان ما قدرت أخدمهم
ثلاثة أرباعهم ما استفدت منهم، واختفوا من بكرة، ما عاد شفتهم
أعلنت عند حساب سناب شات متخصص في حي «عرقة»
ما يتابعه يمكن إلا عدد عُشر المعلن الأول
والنتيجة هي أن جاءني زبائن استمروا معاي
وكانت تكلفة الإعلان أقل من عُشر الإعلان اللي مع الشخص
فحسابات الأحياء، وحسابات المناطق الجغرافية، وحسابات القطاعات
حتى على مستوى الجدوى المالية يبدو أن أمورهم تمشي بشكل جيّد
ضربنا مثال على جريدة «اليوم»
إي في الشرقية صح
مؤسسة «دار اليوم للصحافة والنشر»
وأنا أعتقد أن الأمثلة قادرة على...
والله في أفكار تستغرب أن ليش ما تطبقها المؤسسات الصحفية
كل مؤسسة صحفية لديها كتّاب محتوى بشكل مخيف جدًّا
لماذا لا تنشِئ بعض المؤسسات الصحفية
شركات داخلية أو مؤسسات داخلية لصناعة المحتوى
ومؤسسات للإنتاج ومؤسسات للمونتاج، ومؤسسات للاستشارات الإعلامية
وتقوم باستهداف الهيئات والشركات الجديدة الحكومية
اللي تبحث عن الخدمات وهي داخلة
المطارات أصبحت مطارات قابضة
وفي كل منطقة من مناطق السعودية شركة مطار
مثلًا الدمام ومطار أبها إلى آخره، مطار جدة
تخيل يا عمر، أن هناك ليس دعم مالي حكومي، وإنما دعم بالاستشارة
أن تتحول المؤسسات الصحفية في جزء كبير منها
إلى بيوت خبرة لتقديم استشارات إعلامية
لكثير من الجهات أو حتى توقيع عقود
أنا عتقد أنها تعمل خلل
في البعض، أنا شفت حلقة «بتال قوس» و«عبدالرحمن»
كان في بعض التلميح على موضوع تأجير المباني...
ترى هذا أمر ما يعيبها
نيويورك تايمز كثير من الطوابق مؤجرة من أول يوم لكثير من المؤسسات
ما فيها شيء أنك تستثمر في عقارك، وأنك تستثمر مداخيلك الموجودة
أو حتى مساحات لا تحتاجها تقوم بتأجيرها أمر طبيعي جدًّا
لكن هي فكرة عدم وجود الفكر الاستثماري للمؤسسات الصحفية
أنا أعتقد أن هذا خلل
نيويورك تايمز أنا ما زلت معجب بالنموذج
هو يعتبر أهم نموذج للتحول الرقمي
سأسألك، ممكن تسمح لي؟
خذ راحتك
أدخل دور المقدم لمدة ثلاثين ثانية بس
أيش القسم اللي تتوقع كان نقطة تحول في المداخيل المادية
لنيويورك تايمز؟
الاقتصادي؟
لا
لك محاولتين وبعدين
صعب أني أسألك على كل القسم، وتقول: لا وننتهتي المقابلة
الفني؟
لا
خلصنا محاولتين
الطبخ
الطبخ؟ عجيب
نيويورك تايمز أول شيء بعدما أنشؤوا...
على فكرة جلسوا من عام 1996 وبعدين 1999
وبعدين من عام 2011 إلى عام 2020
بدأوا يحققون مداخيل في الأونلاين أكثر من الورق
لكن كان عندهم تجربة في موضوع تطبيق الطبخ
الـ (NYT Cooking App) «إن واي تي كوكنق أب» موجود
عدد من قاموا بعمل تحميل للتطبيق 4 مليون شخص
ما أعادوا اختراع العجلة
كان عندهم مواد ينشرونها من أول إنشاء نيويورك تايمز
عن الطبخ في قسم الطبخ
قاموا بعمل هذه الوصفات بشكل تفاعلي على تطبيق، وأطلقوه
فجأة أكثر من 17 ألف وصفة طبخ موجودة في تطبيق
يصبح 4 ملايين عملية تحميل واشتراك
حتى هذه اللحظة أكبر مداخيل لها من موضوع الطبخ
فالصحافة المتخصصة مهمة، وعدم اليأس
أنا أتمنى أن ما أحد يفرح لما نشوف مؤسسة صحفية منهارة
أنا ما أعرف أيش النصر الشخصي لبعض الأشخاص
لما يقول: والله انهارت هذه المؤسسة
هناك عوائل تقتات على رواتب هذا الصحفي أو ذاك
حينما تنهار مؤسسة إعلامية ينهار بيت خبرة
تنهار العوامل الداخلية في بيت الخبرة هذا
ينهار كتابة محتوى جيّد، ويصبح هناك محتوى هزيل يُقدَّم لك
يصبح هناك متطفلين على المهنة يفرحون بانهيار هذا الشخص أو ذاك
يفرحون بانهيار المؤسسة الإعلامية لأمجاد لا أعرفها صراحة
ما هو الهدف من فرحة شخص بأن مؤسسة إعلامية قد تختفي؟
أنا راح أسألك الآن مجموعة من أسئلة أصدقاء اللي، ما شاء الله
تفاعلوا كثير وأرسلوا لنا مجموعة
سأبدأ بسؤال لطيف، أظنه هذا جزء من حقول الألغام اللي تمشي فيها
السؤال يقول: 2015، مع حفظ الألقاب لهم جميعًا
2015 «عادل الطريفي» و2017 «عواد العواد» و2018 «تركي الشبانة»
و2020 «ماجد القصبي» و2023 «سلمان الدوسري»
أصحاب المعالي اللي تولوا وزارة الإعلام، خمسة وزراء في سبع سنوات
ماذا يعني ذلك من وجهة نظرك؟
معناته أن، إن شاء الله، الإعلام قطاع مهم، والقادم أجمل
والكثير منهم عمل في الصحافة
معالي الأستاذ «سمان الدوسري» عمل صحفيًّا ورئيس تحرير
وكان رئيسي في صحيفة «الشرق الأوسط» وتشرفت بالعمل معه
وهذا دليل على اهتمام الدولة بالإعلام
والطموحات الكبيرة في هذا المجال
وإن شاء الله، القادم أجمل في جميع القطاعات
لكن هذا دليل على الحراك والاهتمام والتفاعل
وشكرًا للصديق اللي سأل
هذا ينقض سؤالك اللي تقول: أنه غير موجود في مستهدفات الرؤية
الحراك الإعلامي ما زال هو الأهم والأساس لنقل كل هذه التفاصيل
ما راح أجادلك لك في هذه
لأني أقدر أقول لك: أعطني هدف واحد معلَن في قطاع الإعلام
ما راح تلاقي لك جواب
ما فيه هدف معلن، الهدف المعلن أن تصبح الأفضل والأقوى
حتى هذا مو معلن
ما هو بشرط يُعلَن
تشوف الأثر
ما راح نجادل بهذه
في سؤال جميل هنا يقول: متى نرى صحافة استقصائية محلية
تسبق الصحف الغربية في أخبارنا؟
موضوع الصحافة الاستقصائية صراحة مفقود
سؤال جميل جزء منه، نسبق الصحافة الأجنبية في أخبارنا؟
ما تقدر تسبق الصحافة
ما في صحافة استقصائية أجنبية سبقتك في أخبارك
إلا؟
ما في، وين؟
أنت تتكلم على مثلًا «بلومبرق» غطت بعض الأخبار في «نيوم»
قبل أي صحيفة سعودية
إي، لأن الهدف ذكي لما أنا أجي أبغى أخاطب المجتمع الغربي
ما أنشره في صحيفة محلية مكتوبة باللغة العربية
إي، بس ما كان التقرير إيجابي بالضرورة
اللي نشرته «بلومبرق» عن «نيوم» مثلًا
ما يقدرون ينشرون شيء إيجابي يا عمر
لما ينشروا شيء إيجابي يتحولوا إلى علاقات عامة
أو يتحولوا إلى وكالة أنباء رسمية
لا هو يقصد أن الصحفة الاستقصائية ما هي موجودة
هم يقصدون أنه ليش كثير من المشاريع...
مثلًا خبر استحواذ صندوق «الاستثمارات العامة» على حصة من ستاربكس
الخبر نُشِر ولكن الانتشار الأكبر كان لما نُشِر عن طريق «بلومبرق»
«بلومبرق» لها شريحة معينة، وهذا ذكاء في النشر
بس أبو محمد ما أحد شعّب هنا، أنا أقول لك...
ما في
أيش رأيك في الصحافة الاستقصائية؟
هل عمرك مثلًا قرأت تقرير لصحفي مسك موضوع مترو الرياض
من أول عقد إلى آخر عقد، وأيش الإعلانات؟
متى توقف الحديث عن المشروع؟
ما في بيانات، عندنا أزمة عمر في هذه
أتمنى أن الجهات تتفاعل فيها، ما في بيانات
أولًا ما في بيانات
ثانيًا كثير من الجهات وهذا السبب
أرجع وأقول مع كل المحبة والتقدير
إن شاء الله، بعد هذا اللقاء نصبح كلنا أصدقاء
حتى أثناء اللقاء أصدقاء ولا؟
لا، أنا أتكلم على موضوع المشاهير وموضوع الإعلانية
أنا ما عندي مشكلة معهم شخصيًّا
أنا عندي مشكلة مع الجهات الحكومية اللي أدمنتهم
فأصبحت تتجاهل أصلًا الطلبات
تخيل مثلًا لو أنا أتواصل مع «الهيئة الملكية لتطوير الرياض»
وأطلب منها بيانات على موضوع المترو، وأطلب من وزارة النقل
هل سيكون هناك اتفاعل؟ بلا شك لا
جربتم أنتم؟
حاولنا كثير حتى على تفاصيل معينة، حتى في موضوع إجابة معينة على...
كان فيه تجاوب على بعض الملفات ولا يوجد تجاوب على بعض الملفات
ملفات حساسة
أرجع وأقول: لا نخدع أنفسنا
هيئة مكافحة الفساد تنشر من فترة للثانية بعض البيانات والتقارير
أتفق وأختلف
لكن موضوع الصحافة الاستقصائية
لا، هي موضوع التقارير والتحقيقات صحيح أن لديهم سبق
لأن الجهات تريد نشر هذا الموضوع أو ذاك
عبر «بلومبرق» أو عبر «فاينانشل تايمز»
فتيسر مهمتهم
فهي هدف ذكي
تفتح لهم الأبواب
لا تفتح لهم الأبواب بالشكل الكامل
هي تعطيهم ما تريد
ولكنه هدف ذكي لإيصال المعلومة لمجتمع معين أو للخارج
بطولة الغولف في العالمية التي استحوذت عليها السعودية
وصار فيه خلاف وإلى آخره
أنشرها في صحيفة محلية وللا صحيفة دولية؟ صحيفة دولية
من هو الجمهور؟ أنشرها لدى...
لسه أنت قاعد تفترض بأنه هذه كلها بدعم أو توجّه حكومي
أنا أتكلم عن دور صحافة بحت
أن في صحفي صحى الصباح
قال: القضية الفلانية تشغل الرأي العام المحلي
أبغى أشتغل عليها، وأبحث فيها
اعطني قضية مثلًا..
مثل موضوع الزحمة في الرياض والحوادث المرورية ومترو الرياض
أنا أتكلم عن شأن محلي كساكن في الرياض
شوف الأشياء اللي.... إلى حدٍ ما فيه
احنا عملنا مرة تحقيق صحفي على الباصات اللي تدور فاضية
طلع لها هدف، طلع فيه سبب
فترة اختبار
شكرًا، فترة اختبار، وفترة أن السائقين أساسًا يعرفوا المسارات
كأنه تدريب للسائقين لمعرفة المسارات
وصحيح أنها كانت في الليل
والناس يتذمرون رغم أنها كانت في ساعات متأخرة
فكان في صحفية من «اندبندنت عربية»
تواصلت أتوقع مع «الهيئة الملكية لتطوير الرياض»
وكان هناك تجاوب
لكن لما تجيني على ملفات حساسة على موضوع...
أي شيء سيادي وحساس
لا، مش على سيادي، أتوقع حتى على معلومات
على موضوع مثلًا مترو الرياض والشركات المتعاقدة
وليش أُلغي هذا العقد، وكم العقد؟ ما فيه معلومات موجودة
ولا أعتقد أن الجهة راح تعطيك إياها
وأنت عارف وأنا عارف أن الجهات ما راح تعطيك إياها
لكن تجي على تحقيقات، على الشبو مثلًا
كثير من الصحف تميزت في موضوع الشبو وتحقيقات ومعلومات وإلى آخره
التحقيقات الاستقصائية
في واحدة من الزميلات عملت تحقيق ظريف
على موضوع «الأكسنت» و«الألنترا»
ليش دائمًا أكثر المشاغبين في الطرق؟
وعملت واتصلت على وكالات السيارات
وسألت على المبيعات؟ وهل تؤثر الصور النمطية؟
تحقيقات تلامس الناس، وتهم الناس إلى حدٍ ما
لكن أبغى أمثلة على تحقيق استقصائي عملها الآخر
أو الأجنبي لم تعملها أنت، ما في
هنا في سؤال لطيف
يقول: ليش أحس كل المؤسسات الإعلامية أو الصحف
تأخذ معلوماتهم من مصدر واحد وتنشر بتوجه واحد؟
هو يشوف أنه كأنه إذا جاء الحدث
الكل ينشر في توقيت واحد وبلغة واحدة
وكأنه فيه تنسيق بينهم
ما فيه تنسيق، هو الأخبار الرسمية، لما يصير إعلان كبير
على فكرة، لما تشاهد إعلام آخر، كل هذه الأسئلة والتساؤلات تذهب
تشاهد إعلام آخر له نفس الوتيرة
لو تشاهد أي إعلان يحدث سواءً سلبًا أو إيجابًا
كان فيه اكتشفوا في مطار «هيثرو»
وفي كثير من المباني البريطانية أنا ما أعرف اسمها
في شيء متخصص في المباني
ولكن زي ما تقول: فتحات أو شيء في الجدار بسبب البناء
كان غير جيّد، فممكن هذه المباني كلها آيلة للسقوط
الخبر نُشِر، اكتشاف هذا الموضوع عبر جهة رسمية
بعد عشر دقائق في جمع الصحف البريطانية
خبر، الناس تنشر هذا الخبر
لكن يمكن عشان الناس محصورة في تويتر
وكل الناس مسوين متابعة لحسابات الصحف
فلما يشوفون خبر عاجل من «واس»
بعدين يشوفونه بعشر صحف متسلسلة
فيتوقعون أنه منشور بمصدر واحد، وبطريقة واحدة، وبتسلسل واحد
هذا يعود لرئيس التحرير
ما في تنسيق بينكم كرؤساء تحرير؟
لا، هذا يعود أصلًا لرئيس التحرير ويعود للمؤسسة الصحفية، كما قلت
في طريقة إعادة الصياغة، وفي طريقة الخبر
لكن الخبر ينتشر في كل مكان بنفس الطريقة في المؤسسات الإعلامية
المؤسسات الإعلامية البريطانية بكرة تشوف خبر معين لو تأخذ عشر صحف
وأنت تبغى نسوي تجارب
أنا ودي من متابعين ومشاهدين «سقراط» أنهم يعملون هذه التجربة
شوف خبر في أي دولة، لا تتكلم عن العالم العربي، في أي دولة أوربية
ستجده بنفس النمط ونفس الطريقة
تختلف المعلومات على حسب اجتهادات الصحفيين والصحيفة والسقف الموجود
في واحد يسألك: ليش تركت البترول؟
ما تركت البترول، أنا درست في جامعة البترول والمعادن
لمدة سنة ونص تقريبًا، في السنة التحضيرية تعثرت فيها
وبعدين لما خلصت من السنة التحضيرية، وسأبدأ
كان فيه عميد شؤون الطلبة وقتها «سامي خياط»
وكان فيه أيضًا دكتور «عبيد العبدلي» كان وكيل معروف
استضافك في «الأحادية»
وكنت وقتها بدأت في الصحافة
كنت مركز على جريدة «الوطن» أكثر من أي شيء في الحياة
فانتقلت إلى جامعة «الملك سعود» إدارة أعمال
وتخرجت منها إدارة أعمال
وحتى لو درست في البترول ما كنت راح أدرس صحافة
فكان الخيار الأفضل الانتقال لجامعة «الملك سعود»
كان الخيار الأسهل والألطف، لأني كنت مشغول في الصحافة
راح تزعّل طلاب جامعة «الملك سعود» الحين، أن جامعتهم سهلة
لا، بالعكس الجامعة صعبة ليست سهلة، من أقوى الجامعات
ولكن أنا بالنسبة لي كانت تمنحني وقت أكثر في العمل المسائي
اللي هو كان تركيزك الأساسي في الصحافة
ما كنت مركز في الدراسة صراحة، أنا ركزت في عملي وفي شغفي
أهم بالنسبة لي من الشهادة
هذه ما ودّي أقول: نصيحة بعد ويزعلون
فعلًا الشغف والمهنة والموهبة أهم من...
لكنك مع ذلك أخذت الشهادة؟
أخذت الشهادة وأكملت الماجستير، الحمد لله، في الإعلام الرقمي
لكن بالنسبة لي الشغف الأساسي هو للصحافة
في سؤال لطيف مرة يقول: كيف اكتسب عادة الثقة بالنفس
والتحدث بطلاقة أمام الكاميرات والشاشة والجمهور؟
نصائحه للراغبين بتطوير هذه المهارة
هي مهارات شخصية بالأخير
أنا ما أعرف أقدم نصائح، ولا أعرف أنصح أحد
لكن سولف مع نفسك
سولف مع نفسك؟
لازم تتحدث وتحط أسئلة متوقعة
لازم تتكلم ولازم أن تنطلق وتكسر حاجز التردد والخوف
بالحديث أمام المرآة بشكل أكبر
لا تلتفت لمن يقولون: اللي يسولف مع المرايا موسوس
لا، سولف مع المرآة
سولف مع نفسك، سوّي رياضة وامشي وتحدث
لكن هي أتوقع مهارات شخصية ما لها علاقة بـ...
بالاكتساب، ليست شيء يُكتَسب
ما أعتقد أنها يُكتَسب، ما أعرف يمكن أن أكون غلطان
ما أعرف إذا في أحد يصحح لي المعلومة، بس ما أعتقد أنها يُكتَسب
في واحد يسأل يقول: عضوان ضيف من عيار الثقيل
أتمنى تسأله عن باقي حلقات الأمير «بندر بن سلطان»
متى ستعرض؟ وأتمنى تعرض بأقرب وقت
اللقاء اللي أجريته مع الأمير «بندر»
من أنجح أظن إنتاجاتك الإعلامية في مسيرتك كلها
وتابعناه بإعجاب كبير
وكان هو الانطلاق الظاهر لعملكم في «اندبندنت عربية»
كنت تقول: أنك أنت ما نشرت إلا جزء منه
لا، ما قلت كذا، قلت: أنني نشرت أكثر من 60% من الحوار
الـ 40% متى؟
أو خلينا نقول 60% من الحوار معلومات، الباقي حديث ما فيه
فما فيه أجزاء أخرى ما فيه...
ما في شيء يُنشَر، لكن فيه أشياء أحاديث جانبية
ما في شيء حساس ما نُشِر
لكان ليش أحس إنه الجواب مو مقنع؟
مو شرط تقتنع
لا، لكن...
حتى أنت ابتسمت ابتسامة تؤكد أنك مو مقتنع في اللي تقوله
أشياء بسيطة، يمكن أن تُنشَر في وقتها لكن...
أرجع أقول: ما كان في رقابة قبلها، ولا أحد راجع الحوار
ولا أحد قال: تنشر وللا ما تنشر أبدًا
أنت قررت بنفسك وارتكبت جناية علينا كلنا تمنع 40% من حديث هذا الرجل
ما ارتكبت جناية ولا..
أنه هو فوضك، صح؟
هو فوضك قال: أترك لك الموضوع أنت...
يمكن تفاصيل يمكن اللي ما نُشِر تفاصيل فيها أربع أو خمس معلومات
معلومات ما تهم صراحة لحتى القارئ المحلي
بس جزء من الرقابة الذاتية، أعتقد حتى في كثير من الصحف
وجزء منها أيضًا أن فيه أشياء قانونية
فيه كثير من بعض الشخصيات إما متوفاة
وبعض الشخصيات يجب سؤالها عن هذا الملف أو ذاك غير موجودة
فأربع أو خمس معلومات أتذكر
لكن ما كان 40% أو 30% بالمعنى الكامل
هو حديث تفصيلي
فالجواب، الزبدة ما في أجزاء أخرى ولا في شيء راح يُعاد نشره
خليني أختم بسؤال أبو محمد بعد الحوار الجميل
وأقول لك: ما شاء الله تبارك الله، مسيرة حافلة
رئيس تحرير تحت الأربعين
كم؟
تونا بدري
هنا السؤال أن أنت وصلت إلى ما وصلت إليه في هذا العمر المبكر
أحيانًا هذه ما تصير ميزة، أحيانًا تصير مشكلة في إعادة تجديد الشغف
وفي تحديد أهداف جديدة أو طموحات جديدة
فالسؤال، كيف تتعامل مع هذا النجاح المبكر، وماذا بعد؟
شكرًا لك على وصفك أن النجاح مبكر
لكن التجديد مهم وعدم اليأس مهم والتجربة مهمة
والاستفادة من الآخرين مهمة
والاستفادة من تجارب الأساتذة الذين سبقونا مهمة
والإعلام أو الصحافة تحديدًا أتكلم، خليني أقول: الصحافة صناعة متغيرة
الأسس المهنية ثابتة والقواعد ثابتة لكن في تحديات كبيرة جدًّا
والأخبار التي تأتي بشكل يومي والأحداث تصنع طريقة معينة للتعاطي معها
تخطئ وتتعلم غدًا، وتسقط
جاءتك حالة انطفاء؟
كثير
آخرها متى؟
ما راح أقول لك
لا، شوف الانطفاء هي مرحلة مؤقتة في فقدان الشغف
هذه مرحلة تمر لكل الناس
كيف تعاملت معها؟ كيف جددت هذا الشغف؟
أنا أمشي يوميًّا، أسوي رياضة تقريبًا ساعة ونصف إلى ساعتين وصلة واحدة
تعاملت معها وأعطيتها وقتها حتى انتهت بلا مبالغة
تأتي للإنسان مرحلة فقدان شغف لا يعرف لماذا؟
فقدان الشغف أخطر ما هو على...
أنا ما أعرف كم باقي دقيقة لأن...
ما في دقائق ولا في وقت
والله، أعيد من جديد؟
خذ راحتك مرة
أنا أعتقد أن أخطر ما يمر على أي شاب أو أي رجل
في أي عمر من المراحل العمرية المتقدمة والمبكرة هو فقدان الشغف
ممكن تُحبَط وتتخلص من الإحباط
ممكن تمر بظرف مادي أو معنوي وتنتهي منه
لكن إذا فقدت الشغف في شيء، مع السلامة، تنتهي
فأحيانًا إما أن يكون فقدان الشغف له علاقة بظروف تتراكم أو حتى ب...
أنت تقول: نجاح مبكر، أنا ما راح أسميه نجاح مبكر
ما أقدر أحكم على نفسي
وصول مبكر أو نجاح مبكر أو إلى آخره، تسأل سؤال خطير جدًّا، ماذا بعد؟
بعدين تكتشف لا والله، في بعد وتعمل
لكن مرحلة مش انطفاء لكن فقدان شغف جاءت مرة مرتين
والحمد لله، تعاملت معها بأن أتركها للزمن، والحمد لله، انتهت، راحت
القادم أو خلينا نقول بعد عشر سنوات
هل أنا أشوف أبو محمد يقود مؤسسة إعلامية أكبر
وللا في موقع حكومي أكبر؟
والله أنا لو تسألني على...أمنيات الأشخاص
أنا لو تسألني أني أنا ممكن أصير رئيس تحرير وعمري أربعة وثلاثين سنة
ما توقعتها أبدًا
بس أقول لك: كنت أطمح لهذه المرحلة
وكان من أهدافي اللي وضعتها لنفسي
وأنا عمري عشرين أو واحد وعشرين سنة
بعدما بدأت أكتب في صحيفة «الوطن»
كنت أبغى يصير عمري خمسة وأربعين أو خمسين سنة، في هذا العمر
كنت أتمنى أني أصبح رئيس تحرير، الحمد لله
شكرًا «للمجموعة السعودية للأبحاث» وأتمنى، إن شاء الله
أني أنا قد المهمة لرئاسة تحرير «اندبندنت عربية»
في 2018 تم توقيع العقد
بعد عشر سنوات أشوفك في مؤسسة صحفية وللا مؤسسة حكومية؟
أنا بعد عشر سنوات أو عشرين سنة أمنيتي صراحة أني أكون...
دعني أقول لك: مجدد ومؤثر في الصناعة الإعلامية
ليس في السعودية فقط، وإنما في العالم العربي
هذه أمنيتي صراحة
وهذا اللي أعمل عليه وهذا اللي أنا شغفي الوحيد اللي أستطيع...
برضو صعب أن أقول: أبدع، أتحدث عن نفسي
لكن أجيده، هي كل ما يرتبط بموضوع الصحافة
أنا جربت مراسل ميداني في قناة «أوربت» ومُعِد تلفزيوني وباحث
ومراسل ميداني في صحيفة «الوطن»
ومسكت صفحة ورأس الصفحة، وتدرجت فيها
وما زال ترى القادم أجمل والصحافة جميلة جدًّا
وأتمنى أن المؤسسات الصحفية تكون بشكل أقوى
وأن تكون مداخيلها المادية أقوى
أمنيتي أن نرى جيل سعودي صحفي قوي
لأنه إذا جاءت الأزمات، وعاد المواطن إلى الصحافة التقليدية
أو إلى الإعلام التقليدي كما يسموه
لأن ما عاد في شيء اسمه إعلام تقليدي
لكن خلينا نقول الإعلام المؤسسي أفضل
ما في صحفيين جيدين
بعد خمس أو عشر سنوات فلن تشاهد مادة مكتوبة بشكل جيّد
والإعلام له مستقبل، والصحافة لها مستقبل
السعودية مارد نائم تحرك، وتحركت معه المؤسسات الإعلامية
أنا أود أقول أيضًا: أن الإعلام السعودي
هو المؤثر رقم واحد في العالم العربي
الكل يخافك والكل يحترمك والكل يهابك
انظر إلى تجارب الآخرين التي سقطت والتي لم تستمر
وانظر إلى تجارب السعودية
التي بعضها تجاوز خمسة وأربعين إلى خمسين سنة
«العرب نيوز» و«الشرق الأوسط» ومجموعة الإم بي سي وروتانا وإلى آخره
فأنا متفائل دائمًا والقادم أجمل والحياة سعيدة
بإذن الله تعالى، شكرًا يا أبو محمد، شرفتنا و نورتنا
الله يعافيك، شكرًا عمر
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لفهدة القصيّر في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
وفي التحرير: أنس الخليل
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
عبدالرحمن خالد في إدارة التصوير
وفي الإضاءة: ياسر كدشة
في تسجيل الصوت: عبدالرزاق المزي
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
في إدارة الإنتاج: عبدالمجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: رزان دهيثم
هذا بودكاست سقراط، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع